Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
...
Bekannte Startliste
ichALL
ich habe schon an
lull ich dachte schon warum er mich selbst
geil toll
ja ich muss aber noch kurzer auf Youtube posten
lull lull lull lull will
genau max alles klar
Jetzt muss ich mal einen Browser finden, wo ich auf YouTube noch eingeloggt bin.
Was haben wir denn hier so zu bieten?
Ich zeige euch mal ein geiles neues Feature von meinem Neamtool.
Ich habe heute wieder ein bisschen weiter programmiert, während ich hier YouTube-Message schreibe,
dass wir live sind.
Passt mal auf, haltet euch fest.
Äh, wo brauchst du denn immer nochmal was auf YouTube?
Community.
Ahja, passt mal auf, haltet euch fest.
Bestes Feature.
Oh, ein Text weg, stimmt ja eh nicht.
Passt mal auf, bestes, bestes Feature, haltet euch fest.
Haltest du mal einen Vorschau?
Man kann jetzt MP3s und Waffdateien einbinden.
Das werden natürlich alle Reaps unter uns freuen.
Und das Tool erst so richtig attraktiv machen natürlich, vorher konnte man das ja nicht
verwenden.
Oh, habe ich überhaupt, achja ja, aktiviert.
Ich hoffe mal.
So, warte mal, ich wollte ja auf YouTube posten, dass wir online sind, okay, warte.
Auf YouTube hat mir jemand erklärt, das würde angeblich so heißen.
Das heißt nicht YouTube, oder wie die ganz coolen Leute ausspringen.
YouTube.
Weil es ist ja immer, ihr habt ja welche, die müssen alles ganz besonders männlich
betonen.
Da sagt man nicht YouTube oder so, da sagt man auf YouTube.
Semper Video ist so einer da, der sagt die Sachen immer schon so super geil.
Da sagt nicht YouTube, der sagt auf YouTube, nein, auf YouTube, das kann ich keinen Namen
sagen.
Der sagt dann, und jetzt haben wir das Video wieder aufgeladen, auf YouTube.
So ungefähr spricht er das aus, oder?
Und nun können wir uns das Video herunterladen mit unserem Browser, auf YouTube.
Ja, es ist relativ random, das muss man nicht verstehen, was ich von mir gebe gerade, ich
verstehe das selbst nicht.
So, jetzt haben wir es gepostet, Community, YouTube Community, YouTube Messaging System
ist so unglaublicher Crap, das ist so scheiße, ey.
Ich meine, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als YouTube, ich muss mal kurz Kirby ein bisschen
leiser machen, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern als YouTube Inbox, als sowas hier auf YouTube
gab, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, könnt ihr euch hier noch dran erinnern, das da,
kennt ihr das noch?
Kennt ihr das überhaupt noch?
Alter, sah der Safari damals hässlich aus, nein, das ist der Chrome, Chrome mit komischen
Ordnern, aber egal, kennt ihr das noch, das war noch zu Zeiten, wo man auf YouTube sich
ordentliche Nachrichten schicken konnte, wo man beispielsweise sagen konnte, hey guck
mal Max, Business Anfrage, oder wollen wir ein Video zusammen machen, oder irgendwas
in der Richtung, wo man das auch sehen konnte, und da hat sich YouTube ja einfach gedacht,
das ist maßlos overrated, gebated und das schaffen wir ab.
So sah das mal aus, das sah im Prinzip mal aus wie ein Mail-Postfach, ich finde es halt
echt fail, ich meine, wie kommt man auf die Idee, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen,
ich bin nicht eingeloggt, ne, aber wie kommt man auf die Idee wirklich, ja hier sieht man
es noch besser, ich meine, das sah ein bisschen, das sah im Prinzip ein bisschen aus wie Google
Mail, wie Gmail, und das haben sie komplett verschissen irgendwie.
Achja, und jetzt YouTube hat gesagt, das Feature verwendet ja keiner mehr, und weil das Feature
keiner mehr verwendet, können wir es ja auch abschaffen, das ist logisch schlechthin,
ich meine, wenn man das Feature erst so dermaßen scheiße macht, dass es danach keiner mehr
verwendet, dann fällt mir echt nichts anderes mehr ein, das ist absolut next level, das
ist wirklich ahead sind die, meilenweit vorne, ist ja auch nicht Google, es ist ja Alphabet,
ja bitteschön, sagt dir irgendwie keiner, alle sagen es Google, obwohl es ja eigentlich
Alphabet ist, ich sag nicht, dass alles besser war, ich sag, das Message-System war besser,
weil das Message-System jetzt ist scheiße, beziehungsweise, oh ich bin ein bisschen laut
kann das sein, vielleicht schreie ich einfach nur zu laut, das Message-System jetzt ist
einfach gar nicht mehr da, so, ich würde, ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen was anderes
als Kirby an im Hintergrund, das ist auf Dauer vielleicht ein bisschen zu aufdringlich, könnte
ich mir vorstellen, unter Kickstarter können wir ein bisschen kleiner machen, wir müssen
mal schauen, dass die Schriftgröße passt, dass man das alles schön sieht, hab ich den
Text ausgeplandet, dass es losgeht, ja, nice, haben wir eigentlich Quality Options, haben
wir Quality Options, haben wir nicht, ich hab keine Quality Options, aber ich hab extra
runtergestellt, ich hab runtergestellt auf 5,9 MBit, das heißt, es sollten mehr Leute
gucken können, hoffe ich, man weiß ja nie, bisschen kleiner, naja, warte mal, lass mal
gucken, ich mein, wir müssen erstmal in die richtige Kategorie und sowas, also das könnte,
mal gucken, oh, hier ist schon der Weeb-Shit am Start, noch mehr, Projekt-Erkundung, so
rum, der Kickstarter ist auch ein bisschen umständlich geworden, ne, die Seite sieht
ja noch nicht ewig so aus, muss man sich dreimal durchklicken, bis wir das gefunden
haben, und jetzt sortieren wir mal, würde ich sagen, was sortieren wir am besten, wahrscheinlich
nach Projekt-Erstellungsdatum, ist Erscheinungsdatum Projekt-Erstellungsdatum, Moment, neuestes
Projekt oder Erscheinungsdatum sind zwei paar Schub, neuestes Projekt ist, wann das Projekt
aufgemacht wurde, Erscheinungsdatum, wann das Produkt rauskommt, oder, oder meinen die
nicht Erscheinungsdatum, meinen die Erstellungsdatum oder so, warum ist das überhaupt, warum ist
eigentlich mein Kickstarter auf Deutsch, mein ganzer Browser ist auf Englisch, mein Browser
ist auf Englisch, das gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, dass Kickstarter auf Deutsch ist, okay,
es fängt ja schon mal gleich mit einem absoluten Highlight an, wie es aussieht hier, wollen
wir Kirby-Musik weiterlaufen lassen, wollen wir Kirby-Musik weiterlaufen lassen oder Relaxing
Study-Music-24-7-Live-Radio-Deep-House, ich finde der Kirby-Musik ist toll, SYNC-Test,
Sebaro ist auch da, der meisten unterstützt es langweilig, da sehen wir ja nur die Dinger,
die eh schon quasi Hype haben, okay, machen wir mal auf, was haben wir denn, den Thanksgiving-Tai-Kun,
das klingt ja schon unglaublich gut, Backlit, Ancient Zulu, okay, wir machen den ganzen
Klempel mal auf, das Mikro ein bisschen leck machen hier, das ist viel zu laut, haben wir
das jetzt eigentlich alles aufgemacht, ja, passt, okay, erstes eine, gucken wir uns das
ganze mal an, ich bin ja schon wieder, ich bin unschlüssig, ob das so eine gute Idee
ist, weil der Crap-Anteil auf Kickstarter ist schon enorm hoch, ne, also Lead, bekommt
mir bekannt, das ist Kirby, das ist Kirby-Gumi-Race, 10-Stunden-Variante, ja, das ist auch ein
Super Smash, das ist auch ein Smash drinnen, das hier ist auch so ein Zelda-Thumbnail,
was die hier haben, was sich alle Zelda-Fans mal irgendwie wünschen würden, dass Link
und Zelda mal ein bisschen mehr als 3 Worte miteinander wechseln, aber Nintendo sagt
das, nope, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht, overrated, machen wir nicht, ganz unten ist die Spracheinstellung
von Kickstarter, ha, krass, äh, hallo, Englisch, oh, sehr nice, sehr, sehr nice, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr nice, jetzt sieht man auch, dass das hier wirklich newest ist, sehr
schön, ahem, ahem, ahem, okay, ihr müsst mir sagen, mit Musik oder ohne, wir gucken
uns jetzt mal den, ähm, Scheiß drauf, Kirby, tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch,
warum haben die eigentlich immer Hottegrills in den Thumbnails drinnen, na gut, dass die
Leute draufklinken, was sonst, das ist ja bescheuerte Idee, woran soll das sonst liegen, okay,
äh, Moment, Musik aus, gucken wir uns das an, also was haben wir hier zu bieten, ähm,
wir haben hier den Thanksgiving Tycoon, a game where you must cook a Thanksgiving, ah, was
zum Toilett, okay, äh, Deliver, Get Paid, Upgrade, Shop, Get Popular, Repeat, klingt
ja schon unglaublich spannend, er möchte dafür haben 439 Euro, mal gucken, ob es ein
Video dazu gibt, ob es einen Prototyp oder sowas schon gibt, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
jedejenige FDA noch, ein claw, riesige und Herausforderungen, okay, warum mehr, also
jetzt steht noch auf Deutsch, okay, es gibt nichts zu dem Game, das show macht Fail, kilogramms,
ich meine, ich meine es ist ja nichts, das ist ja absolut gar nichts, Skyars ist das
Keine FAQ, keine Updates
Keine...
Ja...
Drei Leute haben gebacked
Okay, wahrscheinlich er
Seine Freundin, seine Mutter, seine Oma
oder irgendwie sowas
Oh ne, das ist Scam, Scam-Arst
Okay, machen wir weiter
Backlit 3015
Ein futuristisches
Adventure-Style RPG
Okay
Mit einer super Story
und noch besserem Gameplay
Okay, gibt's hier was? Gibt's auch nicht
Gibt's nichts dazu
Können wir uns leider nichts angucken?
Ancient Zulu
Neverending Game
Ähm... Endless Story
Creation Game...
Ähm, klingt jetzt auch irgendwie
nicht so der Wahnsinn? Okay, der will
schonmal ein bisschen mehr, der will schonmal 1,7
Tausend haben. Gibt's hierzu irgendwas?
Wir filtern erstmal aus nach
den Sachen, wo es Concept-Arts oder Videos gibt
Äh, übrigens... Moment, ich mach das
Zeug noch mal auf. Vielleicht hat das ja mal NewBlock
geblockt. Nicht, dass
wir jetzt den Anbieter-Scam-Arst
haben, das vom Thanksgiving-
Tycoon. Ne, da gibt's wirklich
nichts
Bei Backlit gibt's auch nichts
Okay
Bei Ancient Zulu gibt's auch nichts
Das ist, äh... Also
ich werd nur Games angucken, wo es entweder Concept-Arts
Videos gibt, irgendwelche Demos
oder sonst irgendwas. Weil alles andere
hängt zu sehr in der Luft
Nee, kann man auch nicht anklicken oder so. Okay
Oh, da gibt's ein Video. Das sind Figuren
Das sind keine Computerspiele
Was?
Eine Chaos Dwarf
Baggage Train
Ist das Warhammer oder was? Was soll das
sein?
Das ist wahrscheinlich für irgendwelche
Paper-Spieler oder so
Was zum Teufel?
1500 Pfund?
Was? Moment, warum ist das so teuer?
Ah nee, das sind die Goals
Ah, das sind die Goals
Also sprich, ab wieviel er irgendwas
herstellt. Ne, ich weiß nicht
Okay, lassen wir uns ihnen mal
erklären, warum der
Chaos Dwarf Baggage Train
das ist, was wir brauchen
Was genau macht man damit?
Was machen wir damit?
Was machen wir damit? Ist das
sind das Gartenzwerge oder ob ich
oder check ich
Ursprünglich hätte ich gedacht, das sind
irgendwelche Warhammer-Geschichten, aber sind's nicht
Also wahrscheinlich ist es für irgendwelche
Pen-and-Paper-Spiele oder so
Keine Ahnung
Aber
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich dafür
Geld ausgeben möchte
Ich glaube, das ist einfach für Leute,
denen das optisch gefällt
Gut, warum nicht?
Wenn's einem gefällt
würde es ja nicht schlecht machen
Okay, next
Present Pursuit
Und
Klingt sehr
Resident Sleeper
Er möchte 21 Euro haben
21 Euro, klingt schon mal gut
Moin Max, wo kann ich günstige Keys kaufen?
Aktuell gar nicht, ich mach mit keinem Key Shop
mehr irgendwas
Ach, wisst ihr
was wir machen können? Wenn wir
ein Projekt durchhaben
können wir ja mal kurz im Chat
also grob schreiben
was ihr dazu denkt
Ja, jetzt nicht irgendwie das Projekt Flame oder so
sondern einfach nur sagen Woodface
oder Pogchamp
Weil ich meine, das steht ja sogar im Titel drin, habe ich mir gedacht
können wir das jetzt auch mal machen
Also was sagt ihr zum Chaos Dwarf Baggage
zum Chaos Dwarf Baggage Drain
Ja, G2A ist mir auch zu shady
mittlerweile, das ist tatsächlich so
Resident Sleeper Pogchamp
Okay, es
naja
Aber es gibt schon ein paar Leute, die finden es anscheinend
optisch nicht schlecht
Nein
Ich würde mal sagen, ungefähr so
ungefähr so
ein Viertel findet es nicht schlecht
Okay, machen wir weiter
Present Pursuit
3-8 Spieler Christmas Game
Christmas Game
Kappa Klaus
Nee, nee, nee, Christmas Game
Das sieht grafisch ja auch schon absolut
ansprechend aus, muss man mal sagen
Wer da nicht in Weihnachtsstimmung
kommt, dann weiß ich auch nicht
Okay
Also, 21 Euro möchte
haben, gibt es irgendwelche
Videos
Außer, dass es
Was genau für
Schnippel sind das hier eigentlich
Okay, man kriegt
was für einen 3D Drucker
Ich finde es immer schlecht, wenn man
anhand eines Kickstarter
überhaupt nicht versteht, was es
eigentlich ist
Sieht aus wie ein Hausaufgabenprogramm
ein bisschen, aber es gibt ja auch
Vorlagen für 3D Drucker
Da kann man sich quasi
Gold Tokens printen
Enthält
Also, was gibt es denn dafür?
Man kriegt 8
3D
Es ist ja auch geil, wenn man mit der
Maus drüber geht, dann verschwindet es
Man bekommt 8
Tokens
Ich bin gerade
ein wenig
Confused
Ich bin echt confused, ich habe keine Ahnung
was da geht dabei
Print Game Shop
Falls euch das Ganze gefällt
Present Pursuit
3-8 Player Christmas Game
Jetzt neu auf Kickstarter
Für 21 Euro
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Bevor wir weitergehen zum nächsten
Also, für mich sieht das eher
nach
Keine Ahnung, eher Richtung so aus
Weil ich vor allem auch überhaupt nicht
genau geht
Also, wenn einer Bock
drauf hat
können wir uns ja angucken
Ich sehe schon die
Resonanz
ist eher Verhalten
Ok, nächstes
Soulbound
Industrial Fantasy
Ok, das sieht schon mal nach einem Spiel aus
was irgendwie so was wie
Concept Art Video
und sonst was hat
Er möchte 4300
Wo sieht man eigentlich von wem das Ganze ist?
Ah, von Andrew Licht
ist das Ganze
Äh, Moment Leute
So, ähm
Also, um was geht das?
What is spell mode?
Lore heavy, das ist schon mal nichts für mich
So viel kann ich sagen
Zu viel Lore ist
ist zu viel einfach
Zu viel Lore geht nicht
Slay Mystic Beasts
Das ist sehr
Generic Fantasy
Industrial Age
Giant Fauna
Corrupted Demigods
Ok, man bekommt ein Special Soulbound Weapon
Und das ist eins hier davon
Concept Arts
Ok, es gibt tatsächlich
Wir können auf der Webseite
die Weapon generieren
Muss ich das malen von Hand?
Nee
What the fuck?
Bounce spiked akimbo hook sword
What?
Und jetzt?
Ah, keine Ahnung
Ähm, so, gucken wir uns das Video dazu an
Also, der will
4093 Euro haben
Für Soulbound
Maus
Alter, kann die Maus nicht mal verpissen?
Nein
Die Maus möchte einfach in der Mitte sein
Ich mach jetzt einfach fullscreen
Dann geht die Maus bestimmt weg
Nein
Alter, Mau?
Ach, das ist offline
Hat er gesagt, Pen and Paper?
Ach, das ist
Kein Computerspiel
Das ist ein Tabletop Game
Man hört nichts?
Wie, man hört nichts?
Was?
So, besser?
Alter, Leute
Jebaitet mich nicht
Guck mal, Leute, hier, da
Ich sehe es doch, dass wir Sound haben
Guck
Wir haben sogar ordentlich Sound
Alter, wenn ihr mich jetzt jebaitet
Kein Jebait
Ich mach jetzt meinen Stream auf dem Handy an
Und dann gucken wir uns das Ganze an
Ob das wirklich so ist
Ich mach das jetzt auf dem Handy an
Und wehe, das ist nicht so, dann gibt's Instant Kick für alle
Alle demonet
Alle gebannt
Aber mich hört ihr gescheit, oder?
Okay
Also, ich hab's jetzt auf dem Handy an
Für alle
Alle, alle demonet
Alle gebannt
Okay
Gucken wir mal
Aber mich hört ihr gescheit, oder?
Okay
Also, ich hab's jetzt auf dem Handy an
Scheiße, das ist echt übelst leise
Das ist echt übelst leise, warum ist denn das so leise?
Das ist übelst leise, warum ist das so leise?
Warum ist das so leise?
Ich mein, guckt mal
Hier, das übelst laut
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum das so leise ist
Die Pause hat man gehört, okay
Was doch immer OBS da treibt
Ja, auf dem zweiten Rechner kann ich nicht probieren, hab ich keinen Sound
Okay
Irgendwie hör ich jetzt wirklich auch den anderen Stream
Da ist was kaputt
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Alter, was ist das?
Ganz komisch
Was machen wir denn da jetzt?
Wenn ihr keinen Sound habt, ist ganz schöner Kack
Ich mein, ihr seht's ja, also es ist angeblich super Sound, ne?
Mehr RAM runterladen, ja
Äh, äh, äh
Ich mein, ihr seht's ja, also es ist angeblich super Sound, ne?
Mehr RAM runterladen, ja
Äh, äh, äh
Äh, äh
Mehr RAM runterladen, ja
Ich, ich geh noch mal kurz, ich setz noch mal Kopfhörer ab und hör mir das auf dem Handy ab,
dass ich weiß, was da kaputt ist oder auch nicht
Es ist gar kein Sound, was ist das denn?
Es ist überhaupt kein Sound vom System, warte mal
Was macht man da jetzt?
Weil der OBS der Meinung ist, es ist alles da
Hä
Jaja, OBS nimmt anscheinend wirklich nur mal ein Mikroeingang
Jetzt müsste ich den Grams ja hören, wenn es auf Monitor steht
Mach ich aber nicht
Kann man den Scheiß entfernen?
Okay
Wir machen jetzt das Desktop Audio Device 2, damit geht es bestimmt viel besser
Okay, damit geht es bestimmt viel besser
Für die Gains
Geht jetzt wieder?
Wieder da?
Alter
Alter, Massive
Huge
Ich weiß auch immer, OBS für Schmerzen hatte
Okay, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob der Sound vom Video wieder geht
Geht, jawoll
Okay, Tabletop-Game
Ich geb' bloß das erste davon
DLCs
Okay, es ist ein Fantasy Tabletop-Game, das habe ich verstanden
Und man hat eine spezielle Waffe
Mit der Mann, wenn das gedacht, Monster best
Monster best
Informationsaufer laut
Ich mein, zumindest hat er eine Vorstellung davon, was er machen will
Okay
Also ich mein, man muss sagen
Die Sachen, die wir glaube ich gesehen haben
Bis jetzt war das heute das Beste
Ich mein, es hat einen ziemlich
Generic Name
Aber ich mein
Er hat eine Idee, was er machen will
Man hat ungefähr eine Vorstellung, was es werden soll
Wie sie spielt, sieht man nicht
Jeder kriegt eine eigene Waffe
Es ist halt so eine typische
Fantasy Welt, ein bisschen industriell angehaucht
Und Monster haben keine Köpfe
Und ansonsten
Sieht halt aus wie Fantasy Game
Okay, es wird gespielt mit normalen Würfeln
Sehr viel Text
Aber ich mein, im Prinzip sieht nicht übel aus
Also
Wer mir das gefällt
Soundbound, Dark Industrial, Fantasy, Kickstarter
Ab wahrscheinlich heute oder so
Am Start gewesen
4390 Euro, was meint ihr?
Was denkt ihr dazu?
Bevor wir weitermachen, nochmal so die grobe
Meinung des Streams einholen
Max, bist du reich? Klar, ich bin YouTuber
Was denn sonst?
Easy
Okay, die Meinung ist schon mal gar nicht schlecht
Also das ist eindeutig das beste Projekt bis heute
Übrigens, eine Sache muss ich nochmal einschieben
Habt ihr die BlizzCon geguckt?
Habt ihr die Diablo 3 E-Mobile-Geschichte gesehen?
Bevor wir weitermachen
Auch genannt Diablo 3 E-Mobile
Was richtig geil war, was wahrscheinlich
Einige nicht gesehen haben, ist der Typ
Das ist der Typ, das ist der Beste
Der Dude ist der geilste
Achtung
Das ist der Typ
Das ist der beste
Der Dude ist der geilste
Achtung
Hey, ich frage mich, ist das ein Out-Of-Season-April-Fools-Joke?
Nein, es ist eine vollständige Diablo-Experience
Auf E-Mobile
Die alle spielen werden
Der Typ ist geil
Und vor allem
Der Typ auf der Bühne
Ist das ein April-Shirt?
Nein, es handelt sich hier um ein voll ausgebautes
Mobiles Diabolo
Diabolo Game
Geil
Richtig nice
Das war genau auch so mein Gedanke, als ich das gesehen habe
Wisst ihr, ich habe mir eigentlich so gedacht
Okay, Blizzard macht jetzt ein bisschen
Bullshit wird angekündigt
Mobile Games
Irgendwie, was weiß ich, Diablo 3
Switch DLCs, was weiß ich
Und am Ende, ich dachte, ich dachte
Ich dachte, am Ende kommt
So der Hammer, am Ende kommt dann auch
Irgendwie
Keine Ahnung, so einen 25 Sekunden
Diablo 4 Teaser oder sowas
Ich meine, ihr erinnert euch da noch
An
An Elder Scrolls 6
Ich meine, das war im Endeffekt
Der Teaser war
War nichts, ja
Der Teaser war lachhaft
Sowas hätten die für Diablo machen können
Ich meine, guckt euch den Elder Scrolls Teaser an
Da ist nichts
Das wars
Mehr hätten die für Diablo 4 auch nicht machen müssen
Alter
Ich meine
Man muss doch nicht mal was zeigen
Von dem Game, ja
Einfach so wie Elder Scrolls 6
Einfach das Main Theme abspielen
Was Diablo nicht hat
Glaub ich zumindest, mir fällt es nicht ein
Und hinschreiben
Diablo 4
Oder sie müssten ja nicht Diablo 4 sein
Sie könnten es ja auch irgendwie
Diablo NG
Was auch immer, irgendwas
Irgendwas, wurscht
Aber nein, Blizzard bringt Diablo E-Mobile
Raus und denkt sich
Wir sind schlauer
Ok, machen wir weiter, Kickstarter
Ja, sehe ich genauso
Ich hab auch nichts prinzipiell gegen das
Mobile Game
Mobile Crap
Dreck eigentlich, also ich hab schon was gegen das Mobile Game
Aber ich hab nicht prinzipiell was dagegen
Dass sie Mobile Games machen
Ich find's halt bescheuert, dass quasi
Alle Welt wartet auf ein neues Diablo
Und ist da übelst scharf drauf
Und Blizzard macht so, und wir haben was Neues
Richtig Geiles am Start, zeigen sie Gameplay, zeigen sie Gameplay
Und denkst dir so, ha
Ich weiß ja nicht
Und dann kommt da Diablo Mobile
Naja
Ok, machen wir weiter, Kickstarter
6.692 Euro
Ein Strategie Koop
Was, Moment
Jetzt muss ich, das muss ich verdauen
Ein strategisches
Kooperatives
Spieler
Gegen Monster
Role Playing Game
Board Game
Bam
Heutzutage sind Spiele nicht einfach nur noch
Shooter
Oder RPG
Oder Adventure, heute hat man
So einen langen Namen was man ist
Also ein Strategie
Kooperative Player
Versus Monster RPG Board Game
Und geht noch weiter
Mit mehreren
Mit mehrfach verzweigter
Magischer Progression
Evolution
Kooperation
Und Adaption
Awaken Dream
Ich hab irgendwas im Hals
Sehen was hier los
Design and Illustrated
Also ich muss sagen
Das Konzeptart von dem Game vorher
Hat mir deutlich besser gefallen
Aber vielleicht bin das ja auch nur ich
The Realm of Dreams
The Realm of Dreams gibt es irgendwie
Die Karten sehen
Irgendwie
Verbesserungswürdig aus
Nein
Artworks drauf oder so
Irgendwie von dem Spell
Mit Würfel
Ok, gibt es da ein Video zu irgendwie
Nee, gut
Kann ich nichts weiter zu sagen
Wär schön wenn man ein bisschen mehr gesehen hätte
Aber anscheinend ist das auch ein
Ist das jetzt, ich verstehe
Ich vermute mal
Das ist ein RL Spiel, oder?
Board Game, also ansonsten würde da
Irgendwie so was stehen wie Card Game
Also sprich so was wie Hearthstone oder so
Aber das ist anscheinend was, was man offline spielt
Aber dann könnte man die Karten doch erst
Recht hübscher machen
Wenn das anspricht
Awaken Dreams, our fate is in your hands
Kickstarter seit heute
Oh je, ist das Französisch?
Oder Spanisch?
Oder Portugiesisch?
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Spanish
Spanisch
Schwarmtaktik
Achso, man kann übrigens jetzt ja auch hier irgendwo
Übersetzen machen
Dachte ich
Er möchte 4000 Euro haben
Das ist auch
Sag mal, gibt es vielleicht auch noch irgendwie
Ich meine
Wir haben hier schon nach Games
Elektronische Spiele, also irgendwie
Computerspiele, Konsolenspiele oder so was
Oder neue Konsolen, das sind alles Brett Spiele
Bis jetzt
Sieht für mich persönlich
Vollkommen uninteressant aus
Aber zumindest haben sie ein Video
Sie haben Erklärungen dazu, wie das Game funktioniert
Könnt ihr euch ja noch mal angucken, wenn euch Kartenspiele interessieren
MyChamp
Alarp
Live-Action-Rollplay
Oder was?
Was zum Teufel
Ist das?
Das ist eine Einladung für einen
Rollplay
Stells, oder?
Ja, das ist Live-Rollplaying
Live-Action-Rollplaying
Das ist nichts für mich
So
Vielleicht kommen wir jetzt ja mal zu den
richtigen Spielen
3D-Printable-Miniatures
Das sieht schon mal ganz gut aus
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz nice aus
Hier das Zeug
Man muss ja irgendwann mal
Richtige Games kommen
Das ist auch wieder für Brett Spiele
Oder irgendwelche
Dungeons & Dragons
Kampagnen, wo man halt
Zeugs braucht. Ich mein, dafür ist das bestimmt ganz cool
Weil man nicht einfach nur eine Karte hat und sagt
Da steht jetzt ein Turm, sondern
Wenn da auch wirklich ein Turm steht, das ist bestimmt ganz nice
Voila-Cat
Endlich, endlich mal ein Game
Für den Computer
Ein Spiel und kein Brett-Spiel
Ist Chromium eigentlich privater als
Chrome oder warum benutzt du das?
Das ist eine gute Frage
Ich weiß nicht
Ok, gucken wir uns mal
Gucken wir uns Voila-Cat an
Voila-Cat
Android
Platformer und Android
Widerspricht sich das nicht irgendwie
Android Everyone
Ist das nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen
Aber egal
Gucken wir uns mal an
Also 1€ ist schon geplatscht
1,50€ will er haben
I'm creating my very first game ever
Ok, achten Leute, haltet euch fest
Voila-Cat in the house
Was?
Ach, das sind Screenshots
Kitsola
Ich weiß nicht was Kitsola ist
Wahrscheinlich irgendein Android Game Framework oder so
Wenn einem das
Wenn einem der Art Style gefällt
Und man gerne einen
Niedlichen Android Platformer hätte
Voila-Cat Kickstarter
Seit heute
5 Tage verpleimt
Doch nicht seit heute anscheinend
Braucht bloß noch 55€ um
Gefounded zu werden
Von Samick Garras
Also Leute, wenn ihr da Bock drauf habt
Dann haut mal rein
Was sagt ihr zu dem Game?
Erstes Game was wir heute gesehen haben glaube ich
Kitsola ist ein Online Movie Maker
Erstes Spiel was wir heute gesehen haben
Der Rest war ja noch Tabletop Geschichten
Voila-Cat
Ok, was haben wir als nächstes?
Kenne ich das nicht?
Ne, das war was anderes
Ich dachte das ist so ein Teil Map Editor
Den es auf GitHub gibt
Das ist quasi für Content Creator
Also für Spielehersteller
Content für Map Forge
Ich glaube das müssen wir uns nicht angucken
Das betrifft uns jetzt nicht so wirklich
Da sind halt irgendwelche Assets drin
Mit denen man dann Games machen kann
Ok, ähm
Next
Ach so geht das
Ich hasse so Endlos Scrolls ein
Lama Pharmat
Ok, ich ahne schon Schlimmes
Ich ahne Schlimmes
Ok, was haben wir denn hier schön?
Das ist auch wieder Brettspiele, wollen wir nicht
A Game of Furious
Kitty Politics
and...
Was zum...
Das ist ein Offline Game, oder?
Aber Sachen mit Katzen drauf
Das geht immer
Der Pursident
Ja, vom Style her ist der schon mal ganz nett
Wenn einem das zusagt...
Wenn einem das zusagt, dann
Könnt ihr euch das ja mal angucken
Fehlt noch ein bisschen was, sind aber auch noch
28 Tage to go
Lama Pharma Drama
Och Gott
Ich ahne Schlimmes
Hallo, was ist Lama Pharma Drama, fragt ihr vielleicht
Ja
Lama Pharma Drama ist das hippe neue Karten-Game
Das ich auch schon gearbeitet habe
Und ich auch
Hallo
Ok, Bilder gibt es nicht
Ok, das ist auch ein
Card-Game mit Lamas
Was? Warum?
Für zwei Spieler
Ok, wer gerne ein hübsches Lama
Card-Game haben möchte, mit
vielen Lamas drauf und bestimmt ganz tolle
Gameplay
Was?
Ok, ich hab vergessen wir sind auf Kickstarter
Und was sagt ihr Lama?
Beste, hä?
Warum nicht? Ja, warum nicht?
Sag ich ja, wem es gefällt
Kickstarter, noch 28 Tage
Titan...
Oh, Makina
Makina
Kina
Titano
Maschina
Was?
Weiß nicht wie man das genau ausspricht, aber das ist auch vollkommen irrelevant
Gucken wir uns mal an
Moment, ist das wieder
ein Card-Game?
3D
Game, Design, Discover, Defend
Das ist wieder ein Offline-Game
Sag mal, das besteht ja fast nur aus
Offline-Games
Sieht zumindest schon mal relativ
hochwertig aus im Vergleich zu den Sachen
die wir vorher gesehen haben
One Player
Jailbreaker
Sag mal, warum sind das alles Board-Games
Streamer-Card
Card-Shredding-Game
Was zum Teufel?
Nein
Mobile
Turn-based Multiplayer
To compete against each other
Na, da bin ich schon mal gespannt jetzt
Ah, ja
Gut, aber wir gucken mal kurz, ob wir das
filtern können
Wir sind hier bei PearMining, vielleicht können wir das filtern
More Filters
All Projects
Mobile Games
Videogames
Filtern wir es doch einfach mal nach Videogames
Ok, jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal
PearMining an
Was zum Teufel?
Ja, kann ich nichts zu sagen
Fast-paced
Multiplayer-PvP-Card-Game
Moment, ist das auch wieder offline?
Ist das offline?
Board-Game?
Tabletop-Game, ok
Lemon
Indie-Game, that will change your life
Wenn sonst nichts ist
Lemon
Videogames
Wo bin ich?
Wie bin ich hier?
Warum bin ich auf Kickstarter-Page?
Alle diese Fragen werden beantwortet
Und...
Dad!
Ich dachte ich würde kommen und ein paar extra Stunden messen
Ist... ist das das Ding?
Ja Bob, das Ding ist das Konzertabott
Ich habe dir nicht gesagt
Oh, oh
Das ist der verdammte Bob's Fun-Chamber!
Nein, nein, nicht ein Fun-Chamber, Bob.
Es ist ein kleines bisschen Spaß.
Wie soll ich auslöschen, wenn du nicht schüttelst?
Mann, bleib nicht wütend. Ich habe Donut getragen.
Wegen des populären Bedarfes hat der Entwickler entschieden uns nicht zu verlassen.
Aber er braucht Fundamente für Software-Services, Morgers, COMP, etc.
Was braucht das?
Nein, Bob. All das, was er fragt, ist ein bisschen Unterstützung, um die Ressourcene der Kammern zu sichern.
Wir brauchen den Fun-Chamber.
Bob, es ist nicht ein Fun-Chamber. Es ist ein sehr elabertes Experimental-Festival.
Wir haben Taktoren, Turretten, Lasern und sogar eine Art Galerie.
Die Supporter können auch eine spezielle Version von ihnen bekommen, die sie nicht verdienen.
Das Spiel ist sehr angenehm, aber wenn du so ein Ding bist, dann bist du glücklich.
Wir werden es mit allen neuen leichten Leveln packen, die hinter der Szene stehen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich gerade sagen soll.
Ein anderes Content, das zu sauer ist für den Standard-Build.
Wir hoffen, dass ihr alle wunderschönen Test-Subjekte in unserem Chamber im Monat Mai seht.
Okay.
Lämmen.
Nur noch 42 Tage to go. 112 Euro vorn 2634.
Wer da Bock drauf hat, haut rein. Lämmen.
Hat es euch überzeugt, Leute? Schießt los.
Hat euch das Game überzeugt?
Aber schon mal die Nächsten auf.
Soundtrack.
This is your life.
Das sieht nicht so prickelnd aus.
Das Spiel ist sehr angenehm.
Und das Spiel muss etwas nur zu bieten.
Das nächste Spiel sieht aus, als hätte einige etwas danach gedacht.
wie hieß das wüstenstells ps3 wie ist das noch mal
journey ja genau
erinnert mich wirklich ein bisschen an journey
auch so mit der musik dabei und das rumgeslider auf dem dünn
ich meine es sieht bis jetzt stimmig aus
aber ist das wirklich das spiel was wir brauchen ja das muss ja jeder jetzt für sich selbst wissen
also ich muss sagen das sieht optisch schon echt nicht jubel aus das gefällt mir das können wir
bookmarken dafür könnte man eventuell sein geld ausgeben läuft noch 30 tage ist anscheinend auch
schon auf steam wie kann es schon auf steam sein wenn es dann nicht gefauntet ist aber auf gut
glück weil er sagt er arbeitet schon seit zwei jahren dran also ich muss sagen grafisch sieht
auch stimmig aus das ist natürlich jetzt kein kein battlefield 5 oder so von der grafik ja
ist ja auch ein komplett anderer stil und sieht recht stimmig auch aus von den vom licht her und
von die animationen sind doch ganz nett er sieht ein bisschen nach wenig fps aus aber das könnte
es auch einfach am gif von einem video her liegen also ich finde es optisch nicht übel und wenn sich
das gut spielt könnte das was sein wie gesagt ein bisschen erinnert mich an journey die frage
ob das nicht zu eintönig wird wenn man da nur rum läuft und rum stampft und puzzelt okay es ist
mehr puzzle als johnny aber der grafikstil gefällt mir das sieht halt übel nach johnny aus hier mit
dem wüstenstel dabei ok ja das ist ganz nice also leute das gefällt ich piste es euch mal in chat
das gefällt kann eine deutsche produktion hier unterstützen aus bielefeld und es sieht optisch
ganz nett aus oder was denkt ihr so ok was das nächste an epic in you epic
in you turn based strategy leute ich habe kein chat mehr auf meinem handy was da los doch geht
ok gucken wir weiter also das nächste zu biegen epic in you epic in you ach was auch immer so
dass da 30.000 euro goal 5.000 856 euro ist schon gebacked also ist 2d
epic in you 2d stellts so teil 2d stellts
progas alter es hat ein bisschen sogar ich weiß es ist 2d aber es hat für meinen geschmack
sogar schon ein bisschen wenig grafik für 2d ok sie singen teil based hast die halt
verschiedene environments schreiben sie auch oben hin und das game kommt für linux das ist
natürlich schon mal ein pluspunkt das ist schon mal ein pluspunkt mir fällt übrigens
gerade ein ich muss noch mal ich muss mal jetzt kurz werden und jetzt muss geerdet werden gepasst jetzt
ist geerdet funktioniert ok ich sag mal so es ist turn based ist nicht unbedingt mein spiele
genre was nicht heißt dass das spiel schlecht sein muss also wenn es euch gefällt 27 tage to go
ok bei der überschrift bin ich schon mal sehr skeptisch aber das ganze ist schon fast
gefaundet 28 tage to go aus reich ja wick in island ok
was zum teufel soll das sein
was was sehe ich da gerade
ich weiß ja nicht es sieht aus als wissen die was wir machen aber es ist weder optisch
mein fall noch sieht es für mich so aus als gefällt mir das zu spielen zumal es ja irgendwie
so eine party game ist oder sowas deswegen denke ich mir das klingt schon schlimm das
klingt schon schlimm wobei man sagen muss ich mein es ist zumindest schon mal zu einem fünftel
oder so gebacked sieht optisch gut aus wie ich finde ja finden sie also es ist geschmackssache
mein fall ist es nicht aber ist mein ist dafür jedem seins gefallen und deswegen sage ich auch
es ist halt man sieht dass die leute wissen was sie machen ist so ok ich ahne wieder schlimmes
hex game
ja flugzeuge
flugzeuge mehr videos von flugzeugen ja ok was zeigt doch mal game braucht
keine videos aus dem zweiten weltkrieg ok das ist gameplay wie es aussieht also hex fällt
strategie stellt back on your desktop vor desktop war das vorhin ein flash game weil es jetzt vor
desktop ist game already successful on ipad ein iphone ok das spricht jetzt nicht unbedingt für
das game aus meiner sicht ok also mein persönlicher fall ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt es kommt aus
aus franz kommt oder wie man das ausspricht wie spricht man das französisch aus moba jawoll
und er will nur 556.845 euro ich würde sagen da müssen wir gleich verplatschen oder er hat
zwei backer schon ok gucken wir uns mal mobile pc game based on historical mythological
characters mobile device ok um ein mobile game zu machen brauchen eine halbe million
das ist ja das ist ja ein schnapper ein schnapper auch vor allem bei dieser grafik schon ein absoluter
schnapper es es es es riecht ein bisschen nach skammer muss ich ehrlich sagen alle gucken wir
es uns mal revival gaming ok das ist kamas oder
oh diese effekte diese effekte alter was
was ist das ist ein game von 1995 oder was das ist so smite für arme oder was
oder haben sie einfach mal natalie portman oder was was ist das was zum teufel skammer
das ist das ist fremd schämen das game ich hab guckt euch als das gameplay
der fack hat der halbe million ist klar leute ja
auch die haben youtube channels was solls jetzt angucken hardes das hat das meint das haben wir
doch gerade schon geguckt das haben wir doch gerade schon geguckt super bewertung ok leute
was denkt ihr becken oder nicht becken skammer oder nicht skammer der hat für right games
gearbeitet ich habe so meine zweifel dass das stimmt können wir mal nachgucken ob es
den typa right games wirklich gibt und ob er das überhaupt ist right games findet man
jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich was zu und wir gucken uns jetzt gucken uns mal die
webseite vom entwickler an also eins muss ich sagen die scheinen das auf jeden fall
ernst zu meinen es sieht jetzt nicht aus wie skammer aber es sieht halt einfach nicht gut
aus forum moment das ist kein forum gut was auch immer also wer dem projekt zum erfolg
helfen will ich meine es fehlen ungefähr noch rund eine halbe million euro wer zu viel
geld hat ich mal easy das hart moba gamut epic graphics das ist wirklich das ist ja
das nächste dota und das nächste loll und die müssen alle müssen sich jetzt echt ganz
ganz warm anziehen wenn das hart rauskommt ok weiter gehts kreow god simulator bekomme
a powerful god and rule your way in die pc game building strategy strategy simulation
and good old fashioned smiting achso ja weil man ja ein gott ist ok der gott simulator
das heißt das hat uns natürlich gefehlt da hat die welt noch drauf gewartet 634 euro
von 15.000 ha ha wie machst du das ich finde das geil wenn ich comments vorlese ne und
die so wörtlich vorlese ha ha wie machst du das wenn du jetzt sagt dass dann ein p
bekommt ja nice das habe ich selbst programmiert denn das das tool kann auch mehr ich kann
sagen jetzt jetzt kann ich sagen ich kann ich also egal was ich sage ich kann ich habe
hier alle möglichen bildchen drinnen man kann bildchen machen wie man lustig ist und
das ding kann mittlerweile sogar wave sounds und bildchen abspielen zum beispiel ok schauen
wir uns mal an der kreow gott simulator ohja grafisch schon mal komplett next level da
hat ne monopoly figur ungefähr ein monopoly haus mehr details ok schauen wir uns das ganze
mal an ich darf die sachen nicht immer gleich schlecht machen schau mal mal schau mal mal
zeig mal den kreow gott den gibt es auf github es gibt die alte version gibt es auf github
die neue version gibt es auf github wenn ich noch ein paar sachen eingebaut habe frei
für jeden dann zu verwenden es gibt nur die alte version auf github die so rudimentär
ähm ne ausrufezeichen meme board oder meme tool ist es das ist aber die alte version
die macht aber rudimentär ungefähr genau das gleiche wie die hier die neue kann aber
noch ein bisschen mehr ok also gott simulator text viel zu viel text unity was sonst aber
warum unity mit unity kann man auch gute spiele machen es gibt ein spiel was millionen von
leuten spielen wo kaum einer dran denkt dass es in unity ist und jetzt ist die frage an
den chat von was rede ich ein paar von euch wissen es bestimmt
also ich finde ich finde die laufanimation ist am besten alter leute fortnight wer hat
gesagt fortnight ist unity und das muss man nachgucken wer erzählt fortnight mein fortnight
ist sowas von offensichtlich unreal das ist sogar vom hersteller und unreal engine fortnight
ok jetzt müssen wir jetzt leider muss ich euch exposen also fortnight wer sagt fortnight
realtime strats sagt fortnight finny sagt fortnight nifty doll sagt fortnight alter
leute ja ja ja ja ja ja ja anzeige ist raus der gott simulator ich weihe natürlich hartstone
hartstone ist unity hartstone kennt eigentlich jeder hartstone ist unity das wissen viele
nicht also man sieht man kann auch sehr erfolgreiche spiele mit unity machen gibt es ein paar
bilder aus dem editor und sowas man kann sehr erfolgreiche spiele mit unity machen
und es gibt wenn er ins unity showcase kommt gibt es noch jede menge mehr unity games die
erfolgreich sind ja sau viele sau viele auch auch ein paar auch ein paar indie games also
irgendwie was hollow knight ist beispielsweise ist ist unity pathfinder das neue ist unity
was gibt es sonst noch so mir fällt gar nicht so es sind sau viele bekannte sind sind sind
unity auch richtig gute spieler also das sagt überhaupt nix aus dass das unity ist ok man
hat es leider nicht so wirklich viel gesehen was was es ist ich würde mal sagen es ist
so ein bisschen in der richtung von black and white und siedler oder sowas in der richtung
würde ich jetzt mal da rein interpretieren das heißt wenn das euer spiel genre ist wenn
euch das gefällt wenn ihr den bock drauf habt dann 21 tage to go fehlen noch 15.000 euro in
your face it's it's money it's life könnte backen wenn er wollte next galactic train spotting
simulator er möchte insgesamt 727 euro es gibt kein gameplay video es gibt audio artwork
es gibt beharrte beine gut gucken wir uns das oh jetzt kommt was für die für die weeps unter
uns seht ich sehe ich sehe schon kommen kann man was gucken ich dass ich irgendwelche sachen über
sehen habe was passiert wenn kickstarter fail schlägt mit dem geld das ist eine gute frage ich
habe glaube ich noch nie ein kickstarter projekt gebackt was nicht was nicht gefaunt wurde ich
vermute mal dann schlägt das founding fail und die leute kriegen geld wieder weil kickstarter
gibt es ja wahrscheinlich bloß bei erfolgreichen founding an den typen das reingestellt hat ok
so games gehen eigentlich prinzipiell immer gut auf kickstarter deck suxo blood droplets horror
visual novel love kill try not to die probably die anyway naja ok die hälfte hat das schon
ungefähr zusammen und für alle wiebs unter uns gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
kfc warnung achtung leute
was genau gucke ich mir gerade an
was was genau ist das ich war ein außer wir haben jetzt noch nichts gesehen außer irgendwie
so ein avatar der links und rechts wackelt ok keine ahnung das sagt ja einmal absolut überhaupt
nichts aber dadurch dass es halt krasser weep ist es ist natürlich die hälfte schon mal
gefaunt das ist klar bringt was ich ja bei anime charakter immer so geil finde bei den typen bei
den typen das hast ja ganz oft ich gucke ja nicht viel also paar sachen kenne ich auch ich finde
es immer geil du hast ja immer so den den den so diesen den zurückhaltenden typen der der
eigentlich nichts anderes macht außer irgendwie an der ecke rumzulungen und wenn irgendwie einer
was sagt macht er kennen das hast du da hast du charaktere die machen die ganze zeit nichts
anderes wie irgendwie rumstehen waren das war es dann nächste folge ok keine ahnung was das sein
soll ja es gefällt so blatt wie heißt so so so so blatt droplets visual horror novel also easy
back next geht weiter school cover nee school coven was ist was was ist das für ein wort was
heißt coven coven coven ist eine bezeichnung für eine religiöse meistweibliche gemeinschaft
oder versammlung von bis zu 13 aktiven das ist ganz wichtig das ist keine versammlung von
hexen das ist eine versammlung von bis zu 13 hexen nicht einfach 13 nicht einfach irgendwie
fünf oder 13 ganz wichtig das ist illuminati mäßig also so haben wir hier irgendwas
war pedo bär approved wie es aussieht wir brauchen noch einen
brauche pedo bär build für solche fälle für solche fälle brauche das noch mal hinzufügen
ja gut zahmer zahmer für sowas auch die passt das passende bildchen am start ok
ach du scheiße ok da weißt du bescheid da weißt du schon wieder bescheid da weißt du bescheid
ok so aber ich wie ich eben gesagt habe so graben geht immer auf kickstarter ich weiß
nicht wer diese sachen immer alle founded aber die dinger werden immer gefahren ich
meine es scheint zumindest ganz gut gezeichnet zu sein und was auch immer es genau ist wahrscheinlich
halten ihr seid eine visual novel also interaktives text geklicke im endeffekt und die story ist
natürlich auch wieder ganz toll ja eine die nur in der schule ist das ist das gibt es
eigentlich irgendwie was in dieser richtung wo die story nicht anfängt mit er sie erst
ist neu in der schule es ist echt muss so sein ach ja unten steht übrigens auch was
passiert wenn das geld nicht gefaunt wird sprich wenn es nicht gefaunt wird dann kriegt
die krone wieder ja schaffes ich weiß auch nicht aber so visual novels gehen einfach
auf kickstarter immer gibt einfach genug weeps unter uns ok weiter gehts oder was sagt ihr
hier was sagt ihr school kaufen was sagt ihr oh guck mal mit live geplatscht ist einer
von euch gibts zu das ist einer von euch da hat er nur drauf gewartet kannst du auch
mal die bilder zeigen ja sehbaro hier grill in schuluniform grill in badeanzug grill in
unterwäsche und ab und zu mal auch in normaler kleidung natürlich ja aber hübsch gemalt
ist es muss man sagen auch wenn die grafik hier nicht wirklich zu dem zeichen stil passt
aber wir wollen aber nicht so anspruchsvoll sein moca toss gut weiter gehts set after
oh survival game mit zombies da hatten wir ja schon lange nix mehr es gibt ja nur 150
stück es gibt ja nur 150.000 zombie games aber wir brauchen ein neues zombie game ein
2,5 d zombie game ich sag euch leute vor fünf jahren vor fünf jahren wäre das hier instant
found gewesen weil vor fünf jahren waren zombie games der shit ja mittlerweile nicht
mehr soll ich euch übrigens nachher noch mal die neuen meme tool features zeigen ich
habe noch ein paar sachen eingebaut schon schon nice mittlerweile schon nice und außerdem
haben wir massiv viele zeilen code hinzugekriegt hier guck mal wie lang beispielsweise schon
die main javascript datei ist 308 zeilen hässlicher javascript ok also set after oder
sie after sie after klingt jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen kappa pride oder sie after ok
also das üblichste das übliche max sag mal wird es wieder it mythen geben ja ja bestimmt
ich wollte übrigens ein video machen zu job beschreibungen also weil es so viele total
weltfremde job beschreibungen gibt wollte ich mal ein paar angucken ihr video und ein
paar takte dazu sagen so viel schwachsinn dabei ok also sie after gucken wir uns jetzt
an
ok also es an 2,5 d spiel anscheinend interpretiert jetzt mal so rein um aus 2d 2,5 d zu machen
musste man alle farben verzichten geiler namen hatte oder ich meine heißt er heißt schon
das ist ein waldoclone oder was oder was heißt klonen den noise weisler kennt ihr das noch
das ist ein sucht game also das ist vom super vom nicht vom supernetz vom normalen ns gab
es gibt ok gibt sein anscheinend auch aus aus aus bildchen aber ja das sind zu sucht bildchen
da musst du halt suchen wo er ist und anscheinend ist das auch so was in der richtung also sprich
du musst in diesen bildchen irgendwas suchen anscheinend vermute ich jetzt mal hat er gesagt
ja das ist so was in der richtung das war ein kinderbuch ja das gab es aber auch als
game ok grafisch gefällt mir nicht also ich bin nicht gegen 2d games das wisst ihr eine
meiner lieblingsspiele schlechthin sind 2d super Nintendo spiele und es gibt auch viele
gute neue 2d games gegen 2,5 die habe ich natürlich auch nichts allerdings farben wären
schon ganz nice also einfach nur schwarz-weiß ist mir doch ein bisschen zu raw gut 44k quasi
in griffweite wenn das game gefällt noch 40 tage zeit zu becken sie after der name macht
mich fertig das ist sieht aus wie ein boomer aus left for dead plus ohne farbe und ohne
3d ok na ich weiß nicht family pick ross in new game von nintendo moment was neues game
für den nes wie will er das machen gut ich meine baut ne cartridge wahrscheinlich die
farben kann er sich nicht leisten dafür brauche die 44k möglich ok neues game für nes mal
gucken bin ich mal gespannt haben wir denn haben wir ein bildchen von hier youtube youtube
video es war erst mal stylish 4 zu 3
was das ist das das game
was tut er da
das ist mein sweeper ich habe keine ahnung ok das ist das game anscheinend pick ross ich
kenne das nicht sagt mir nichts sagt mir überhaupt nichts ok also ich würde das game normalerweise
nie becken aber es ist ein nes game das ist eigentlich glaube ich das einzige was das
game was man da sagen kann was es halt jetzt rausreißt und ich gehe mal davon aus dass
viele leute einfach sich das deshalb holen also warum nicht mein sweeper so doko viel
tetris ich kenne die grundlage nicht also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich tut man da
irgendwas so so so raus carven quasi ich weiß nicht ich finde es cool dass es ein nes game
ist es ist eine ordentliche cartridge die aussieht wie der ns kart ja aussieht wie der
ns kart es gibt ein lösungsbuch dabei also gesamtpaket scheint eigentlich recht stimmig
zu sein wenn da eben das gameplay anspricht also wer bock drauf hat ich pause nur die
guten sachen wo ich da wo ich denke das könnte man auch ragnarok the beginning of a new age
dieser titel ich glaube es gibt kaum was so an wörtern hier so aus europäischer kultur
irgendwas was mehr für spiele videos filme bücher titel und alles gebraucht wurde alles
ragnarok ok kein video 143 euro action rpg based on vikings 43 euro
minecraft vikings ok leider sieht man doch nicht allzu viel von hätte ich mal gerne
was in action gesehen muss man gerade mal nebenbei was gucken kurz also wenn euch das
gefällt dann haut rein game ist zwar schon gefaunt mit mächtigen 43 warum stellt man
den game bei kickstarter rein und will 43 euro für verstehe ich nicht vielleicht mal einfach
mal gucken ob sie mal prinzipiell jemand interessiert oder so weiß nicht keine ahnung ok aber weiter
tissue tadpole short and very pointless game ok fängt schon mal gut an squiggeling around
and think through for three minutes before moment ja ich ahne auch schlimmes schaffes vielleicht
muss ich gleich den stream ausmachen man weiß ja nicht was da jetzt gleich gezeigt wird
was ich brauche noch das bad war ihm was ist das bad war ihm welches der vielen ist das
ach das ja das das aber das das kann man nicht so schön transparent machen und endlich
viele quasi ok ich will der port gucken wir uns an unity ein spermer zähler auf dem handtuch
ein auf dem taschentuch und was genau möchte uns das game sagen
6.000 828 euro also wer bock hat 1 euro ist geplättet 33 strage läuft das ganze noch
bestimmt nvidia werbung eigentlich das nächste fortnite ok was haben wir als nächstes
requiem augmented reality game ok da will schon mal 17k haben es sieht schon mal irgendwie
nicht so ganz passend aus von der hand in dem spiel aber gut pc vr playstation vr xbox
hat ein bisschen was von dank muss sei auf mein magic was wir letztens gespielt haben
oder plus rl oder kriegt der drache aber kann was was eingeführt hier ok haben wir
den haben wir ein video von ein geiles logo haben sie schon mal da kann einer blendern
der stelzritter guckt euch das mal an der stelzritter so geil guckt euch den ritter
kleiner war der stelzritter guckt sich das fail aus hatten die zwei köpfe
der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter
guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich
das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an
der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter
guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich
das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an der stelzritter guckt sich das mal an
Ihr müsst mir das mal erklären, äh...
Baut ihr ne eigene Brille?
Oder ist das was, ist das ne andere Brille?
Das wird doch nie was!
Ich mein, das ist so ne typische Sache, wo ich sagen muss...
...von der Idee her, eigentlich extrem cool, ja?
Von der Idee, also quasi, dass man ne eigene Hardware hat...
...mit der man halt auch dann ordentlich rumlaufen kann, wenn wir immer der Akku da haben, was auch immer...
Also im Angenommen, das würde funktionieren.
Ne ordentliche, leichte Brille, man könnte draußen quasi Fantasy VR spielen...
...extrem cool, eigentlich!
Aber ich glaube halt nicht, dass es...
...das wird.
Zumal, die Sache ist halt auch die, bei solchen Games, das rumlaufen macht halt die ersten paar Stunden Spaß...
...und danach ist halt die Frage, was gibt's denn für Inhalte, wie ist das Gameplay technisch so?
Und letztendlich ist es nur auch so, wenn ich ein paar, wenn ich lange Zeit am Stück spielen will...
...will ich dabei nicht draußen rumstellen müssen.
Oh, das ist so ein bisschen, ich mein, Pokemon, ja, Pokemon Go, da sind die Leute ja auch am Anfang übelst darauf abgegangen...
...und mittlerweile spielt's kaum noch jemand.
Kaum noch jemand ist, anteilmäßig, immer noch mehr als bei den meisten Games.
Okay, aber...
...ja, okay, weiß nicht.
...
Naja, ähm, ich, da glaub ich nicht dran.
Und letztendlich geht's bei Kickstarter ja auch darum, ob man an irgendwas glauben kann, um den Kohle zu geben.
Warum haben die eigentlich Bilder von Cars drinne?
Das versteh ich nicht.
Und warum haben die Trailer von anderen Spielen drinne? Und von Cars, warum von Cars?
Weil die uns zeigen wollen, was die Leute schon vorher Geiles gemacht haben oder so.
Weil, keine Ahnung. Also ich glaub da nicht dran.
Ich glaub nicht dran.
Uah!
Was ist das?
Destiny 2 ist zur Zeit umsonst, aha.
Uah, ich hab trotzdem keinen Bock drauf.
Dark Science Fiction Fantasy Adventure made from clay?
Clay ist, ähm, na, nicht Ton.
Lehm, genau.
Ähm, so sieht's auch aus, okay.
Äh, ist schon ganz gut gebacked, läuft noch 22 Tage. Scheint ganz gut anzukommen.
Ist, ist auf jeden Fall mal interessanter Style. Okay, gucken wir's uns mal an.
Laufanimation, FTW.
Was genau schau ich mir da grade an?
Was zum Teufel ist das?
BTF?
Was denn das für Rüssel?
Es geht 3 Minuten 37 so, oder?
Warum müssen das Lehmkreaturen sein in einem Spiel?
Ich mein, es sieht zumindest nicht so aus wie andere Dinger.
Was, was zum, was ist das?
Alter, was ist das?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Jetzt boxen die Dinger auch noch. Ich bin komplett verwirrt. Was, was guck ich mir da an?
Was ist das?
Es ist komplett Exploding Prey, nice.
Also Leute, fehlt nicht mal viel zum Goal, Sluggy Schmoss Pattern Circus.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal irgendwie, ich muss jetzt erstmal auf den anderen Monitor gucken,
dass ich wieder meine Augen an, normale Sachen gewöhne.
Okay, weiter gehts.
Also, wer gerne becken möchte, ein Lehmfigurenspiel, das, ey, da kriegst du epileptische Anfälle bei.
Geil, aber zumindest kann man ihnen nicht vorwerfen, sie werden nicht kreativ.
Oh, wieder schönes Reap Game.
Crimson Cases, ach, das ist quasi, äh, Dings hier, sowas wie, wie heißt es?
Objection, Ace, ach, fuck, wie heißt die Reihe?
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, Leute, Phoenix Wright, Phoenix Wright meine ich, ja, genau.
Ähm, ja, jetzt wirds wieder eingefallen, vielleicht ist noch sowas in der Richtung.
Die sehen ein bisschen geklont aus, die zwei, muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Äh, okay, es ist im Prinzip wieder so eine Art Visual Novel und diesmal eine, die tatsächlich
nicht voll oder fast voll gefounded ist.
Es gibt außer Bilder auch keine Videos oder sonst was, aber Reap Games gehen prinzipiell
immer auf Kickstar, das haben wir gesehen.
Das heißt, das wird wahrscheinlich auch was werden.
Next, bl, wat, Blizzard BlizzCon World of Warcraft PvP Endon.
Moment, seh ich das richtig?
Das ist ein PvP Overlay, der quasi für Leute, die kein PvP können zeigt, welche Spieler
man angreifen soll, seh ich das richtig?
Aber sowas gibt es doch bestimmt schon, ne?
Ein WoW Endon, das ist noch nicht mal eine richtige Hack, das ist wahrscheinlich vollkommen
legal.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Outworld Battle Crowns, alles was Battle Crowns drinne hat, da bin ich schon immer hart am
cringen.
Solang es nicht Outworld Battle Crowns ist, Outworld Domination never felt so good, enjoy
Retro Battle Royale, oh Gott.
Warum?
Warum muss es ein Battle Royale sein?
Okay, wir gucken es uns an.
Da ist diese Dubstep Musik dabei.
Vier Minuten.
Nein, da geht es nicht.
Bevor ich doch epileptische Anfälle kriege, oh, das ist der Master Chief mit zu wenig
Polygonen.
Der Master Chief mit Delle im Helm.
Das sieht wirklich aus, wie der Master Chief dem einen in die Fresse getreten hat, oder?
Bäm, ins Gesicht.
Okay, ich glaube, das kommt für uns nicht weiter an.
Warum?
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Next.
Das ist lustig, eigentlich können wir jede Woche sowas machen, oder?
Was denkt ihr?
Das ist teilweise echt witzig.
Okay, weiter geht es, New Worlds, a Space Colony Sim, 242 Euro von 6278.
Gibt es ein Video?
Die fehlen die Augen, oder?
Der hat keine Augen.
Vielleicht sollte man nicht so komische Planeten besiedeln, sondern erst mal Augen wachsen
lassen.
Okay, Mann, da gibt es doch nicht viel zu sehen.
Next.
Chronicles, Mountains of Madness, das ist genau Lovecraft.
7000 von 10.000.
24 Tage to go.
Sieht sehr danach aus, als wäre es gefaunte Demo available.
Jetzt kann man es vielleicht sogar mal angucken.
Also, gucken wir uns mal an.
Was gibt es denn da?
Horrorstells.
Machs gut, Schaffers.
Okay, es ist mehr 2D, als ich gedacht habe.
Was geht?
Okay, warum nicht?
Adventures gibt es generell zu wenige Gescheite.
Das geht uns in die Mut, sagen sie.
Okay, wenn man auf dieses Szenario steht und auf Pixel Adventures, könnte das tatsächlich
was sein.
Okay, dann kann ich auf jeden Fall die Kickstarter Seite gut gemacht.
Aussagekräftig.
Das kann man sich mal überlegen.
Also, wenn euch das interessiert, BAM, Link im Chat.
Ich habe es auch mal gespeichert.
Gar nicht so blöd aus.
Also besser als die meisten anderen Sachen, die wir heute Abend gesehen haben.
Nächstes Game.
Ist Studio de das...
Moment, was?
Ist das Spanisch?
Portugiesisch?
Das ist ein 3D-Video-RPG-Maker oder sowas.
Weiter.
Quickstarter.
Atari Age 2.
Es sieht wahrscheinlich ganz grausam schlecht aus.
Er will auch nur 100 Euro haben.
One Grill.
Ah, okay.
Wenn man das nicht wüsste, dann hätte man das nicht so richtig erkannt.
Das ist mir schon zu retro.
Na, Leute, na.
So plump.
2D-Action-Platformer.
Game-Exploring.
Exploring-Game.
Okay, es scheint mir zumindest von Leuten zu sein, die malen können.
Wobei es nicht unbedingt mein Grafikstil so richtig ist.
Gucken wir mal.
So plump.
5 Minuten.
Da kann es ja fast zumindest eine Hauptbahn auf.
Wenn Sachen absichtlich auf Cringe gemacht sind, sind sie immer doppelt Cringe.
Nicht weil sie Cringe sind, sondern weil sie es nicht sind.
Und deswegen doch.
Wisst ihr was, Schwein?
Okay, das Gameplay sieht sehr langweilig aus.
Ich habe es gelesen mit den GPUs.
Ich brauche erst mal einen, der sich damit auskennt.
Okay, Leute, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Also, man sieht schon, dass sie das ernst meinen und dass sie sich im Prinzip auch Mühe
geben, aber mir gefällt es nicht.
Das ist so überhaupt nicht mein Artstyle und meine Aufmachung von Games, wie es mir
gefällt.
Man sieht, dass sie sich Mühe geben.
Ja, das ist aber...
Also, mein Fall ist es nicht.
What?
Ich werde zu einem ferngesteuerten Roboter mit einem VR-Deep.
Na dann, zeig mal her.
Wie auch immer das gehen soll.
Was du...
Alles sieht jetzt zum Fürchten aus.
Fünf FPS.
Das menschliche Auge wird komplett ausgereizt hier an der Stelle.
20 Google Class um dich drum herum.
Nicht Google Class.
Google Cardboard.
Ja, also für weitere 94 Euro könnt ihr Real Virtual Reality kaufen.
Was auch immer.
Free to Play Multiplayer Card Game.
Komm, oh Gott.
Only of Female Protagonists.
Jawoll.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
Endlich.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Ach, es ist ein Weep-Game.
Ich dachte, es ist so ein Feminism-Game, aber ist es gar nicht.
Okay, es ist ein Card Game mit Manga und Anime Crills.
Das ist bestimmt so gut wie ge-founded, oder Leute?
Oh, jetzt enttäuscht mich Kickstarter, aber...
Also jetzt enttäuscht mich Kickstarter, aber...
So Games werden auch immer instant ge-founded.
Aber vielleicht sind 10.000 Euro einfach ein bisschen zu viel.
Also wenn ihr schon immer mal ein...
Free to Play Multiplayer Card Game spielen wollt mit nur weiblichen Anime Crills.
Und was einen unaussprechlichen Namen hat, die Luhumia.
Dann habt ihr noch 23 Tage Zeit, das Ganze zu becken.
Weep-Game aus... ist das aus Frankreich?
Okay, da hast du recht, da kann es nichts werden.
Noch mehr.
Also sowas ist natürlich auch schon wieder fast ge-founded.
Diese Visual Novels, warum sind die ganzen Visual Novels immer alle kurz vorm Fountain?
Gibt es so viele Leute in den Spielen?
Das ist aber noch nicht mal so richtig weep, das ist so halb nur.
Nur half-weep.
Kein Gameplay? Na gut, was soll man dabei auch zeigen?
Aber schon fast ge-founded.
Okay.
Xeno Carnage, 16-Bit-Version.
Ein Roguelike für einen PC.
Da gibt es ja auch schon viel zu wenige für.
Gameplay gibt es keins.
Dementsprechend wird das wahrscheinlich auch nicht ge-founded werden.
Also ich finde immer, selbst wenn ein Projekt gute Ansätze hat,
bevor man es auf Kickstarter reinsetzt, ein Gameplay-Demo-Material, so ein bisschen was sollte eigentlich Pflicht sein.
Also mit Pflicht meine ich nicht, dass das Kickstarter vorschreiben soll oder so.
Sondern aus eigenem Interesse für einen...
Entwickler sollte man eigentlich ein bisschen...
Zumal es ja anscheinend auch eine Fortsetzung ist von seinem anderen Game.
Von dem Game hier anscheinend, wie es aussieht.
Okay.
Not only VR Space Shooter.
Ein Euro von 17k. Easy.
Easy Money.
Windows Movie Maker Transition.
War das eine Vita? Moment.
Nee, das ist keine Vita.
Das ist... Was ist denn das?
Smartphone, oder?
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Da kann Starfox einpacken.
Wobei das neue Starfox ist auch übelst mies gewesen.
Auch SWAT 3's gibt's auch noch.
Das sieht aus wie ein Spiel so von 95 oder so.
Das erste Descensor glaub ich ähnlich aus.
Ey, was ist das denn?
Nee, komm Leute. Nee. Nee.
Also wer mithelfen möchte, VR Space Shooter zu fauen.
Habt ihr noch 21 Tage Zeit.
Es fehlen bloß noch 17.086 Euro.
Rhythm Music Based Action Game.
Eins von 150 Euro.
Na, da können wir ja quasi unsere ganze Kohle reinstecken.
Soll das so was wie Ozu geben?
Ach nee. Moment, das ist...
Das ist alles.
Man fliegt aus diesem komischen Polygon raus.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das alles. Man fliegt die ganze Zeit aus so einem Ding raus.
Was? Stolen Content? Was? Hä?
Das ist doch super heksam.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Gute Musik, das ist ja nicht mal von ihm.
Das ist ja schon dabei.
Was? Super Hexagon. Hab ich ja nie gehört.
Ach, das ist von denen.
Okay.
Aber das sieht gleich besser aus.
Pogas.
Headbang. Okay, weiter.
Ah, ganz wichtig.
Ich brauche noch Gatschi Bust Gif. Habt ihr eins?
Gatschi Bust Gif.
Farbe transparent.
Das sieht schlecht freigestellt aus.
Aber das nehmen wir trotzdem als stellvertretend.
Gut.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
6 Euro von 5000.
Das ist Space Invaders in nicht viel schöner als damals.
Ich glaube, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Unity.
Das wird es uns.
Nee, war besten Willen nicht.
10.000 schon von 91.000. Okay, das ist ein bisschen was Größeres, wie es aussieht.
Was haben wir zu bieten?
Das Interface sieht aus wie von irgendeinem x-beliebigen MMO.
Von irgendeinem x-beliebigen älteren MMO sieht das aus.
Ist das ein MMO?
Nee, oder?
Das ist das alte Guild Wars Interface. Genau so sieht es aus.
Wirlwind Barb am Start.
Die Open World sieht schlecht aus.
Guck mal, da ist ja überhaupt nichts.
Stells.
Ich meine, es scheint schon mal zu laufen.
Multiplayer scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich glaube, mehr als bei den meisten anderen Games.
Auch wenn es mich ehrlich gesagt so nicht wirklich anspricht gerade.
Ein Combined Wizard. Ich wollte schon immer ein Combined Wizard sein.
Macht Spaß, okay.
Also 23 Tage Zeit. Haben wir so noch ein bisschen mehr zu bieten?
Ich meine, es macht einen durchdachten Eindruck.
Und anscheinend meinen die es auch ernst.
Wir haben sogar hier mal im Chat das schon gespielt und gesagt, macht Spaß.
Was man zu den meisten Games, die wir heute Abend gesehen haben, nicht so unbedingt sagen kann.
Also Leute, wenn euch das interessiert, Action-RPG ohne Grinden mit PVP-Content.
Dann haut rein, läuft besser als BDO, ja das ist auch keine großartige Kunst.
Dann haut rein, ihr habt 23 Tage Zeit 80K zu bletschen.
Demo available.
Können wir uns vielleicht irgendwann mal angucken.
Null Euro von 87.000.
Ach das ist eine Messe, oder?
Focal Point von World of Gaming Conventions, null von 87.000 Euro.
Mit 87.000 Euro kommt man für solche Messen halt nicht so weit.
Okay, was auch immer, kein Game. Kingdom of Reha. Reha? Ernsthaft?
Das ist für Leute mit gebrochenem Bein oder was?
Dark Fantasy RPG.
Zwo, fast schon 3K gebacked.
Schauen wir uns Kingdom of Reha an.
Ein bisschen Dark Souls-mäßig, so wie der Typ da rumgerannt ist gerade.
Das Nahkampfsystem sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Wenn man aber nur die ganze Zeit das macht, ist das natürlich auch ein bisschen langweilig.
Das ist eher so Dungeon-Crawler-mäßig.
Zumindest rennt man mal schön schnell.
Das finde ich gut, weil bei ganz vielen RPGs hast du immer das Gefühl,
die haben die Renngeschwindigkeit auf 10% gestellt.
Alle Essens gekauft, das kann schon sein.
Für das HUD sieht das Game schon eindeutig zu gut aus.
Das HUD sieht wirklich billig aus.
Ansonsten sieht es ganz okay aus.
Die Frage, wie viel von Ihnen ist und was noch alles reinkommt,
ein bisschen eintönig, ne?
Okay, 21 Tage haben wir noch Zeit.
Warum springt er denn so?
Okay, wem es gefällt, 21 Tage, to go.
Noch Lepigel 33k übrig.
Ah, 32k.
Fantasy Plectmas.
Das ist schon fast ge-founded.
Ohje.
Ohje, ich ahne, das Schlimme ist, das ist irgendwie so ein Simulator-Game, oder?
Ohje, okay, schauen wir mal.
Der Crafting-Simulator quasi.
Hier kann man quasi den geilsten Shit ever craften
und hat kein Game drumherum, um damit dann zu spielen.
Warum nicht?
Ich meine, die Idee finde ich nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob ein, quasi, Crafting-Game,
ohne wo man die Sachen verwenden kann, dann so toll ist.
Aber ich meine, die Idee finde ich schon mal gut.
Außerhalb seines, außerhalb der Schmiede gibt es anscheinend im Game nicht.
Aber man kann wohl ziemlich viel selbst machen.
Also von der Idee her eigentlich ganz cool.
Auf YouTube war mir auch was, okay.
YouTube.
Also wer da Bock drauf hat, Fantasy Plectmas ist so gut wie ge-founded.
Die Jungs wollen auch nur 1756.
Wie kommt man eigentlich immer auf so Preise?
Sagt man nicht 2000, 1500.
Warum sagt man, als hätte man, wisst ihr, als hätte man das so krass kalkuliert,
so nach dem Motto, also wir haben ganz genau nach wissenschaftlichen Untersuchungen festgestellt,
für unser Spiel zur Fertigstellung brauchen wir 1756 Euro.
Ihr, das stimmt, für ein RPG, also quasi in einem fertigen Spiel so ein Schmiedesystem,
das wäre schon sehr nice.
Ob es halt ein Crafting-System ohne Spiel drum herum jetzt so toll ist,
weil ich meine, was machst du mit den geil gecrafteten Sachen?
Ich meine, es ist schon mal cool, so richtig was selbst zu spielen.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Oh, Baked Magic, Original Novel, das Zeug ist immer fast ge-founded,
egal wie viel oder wie wenig Geld die wollen.
Oh, ein Diverse-Cast, jawoll.
Da ist also dann auch für jeden was dabei.
Find ich auch was.
Musik, Moment, was?
Okay, dann gucken wir, es gibt gar kein Video.
Okay, ich dachte, wir können uns jetzt Visual-Novel-Video angucken.
Okay, nice.
Ach, von Dollar in Euro konvertiert.
Ah, siehste, meine Subscriber sind einfach absolut big brain, richtig gut.
Äh, nicht Subscriber, stimmt ja gar nicht.
Wir sind ja auf Twitch.
Zuschauer.
The Cinema Rosa.
If you like Stanley Parable, you love Cinema Rosa.
Puzzle Explorer game with a twist.
Zeig ich mal her.
Äh, was genau geht da gerade?
Ja, die Stimme ist sehr mono.
Also sie vergleichen es wohl mit Stanley Parable, okay, aber man sieht nicht viel,
aber es ist wohl kurz vorm Fountain, 20 Tage to go, noch die Hälfte ungefähr zu Fountain.
Mehr sieht man da leider nicht dazu.
Äh, okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Okay, jetzt kommen ja so langsam die Highlights, wie es aussieht hier aus.
Oh Gott, es wird ja eins schlimmer als das andere.
Schon wieder.
Wie viele Visual Novels haben wir denn?
Blockchain Adventure.
Na, das hat noch gefehlt, ey.
An Action Adventure RPG based on history can the real world implement a blockchain.
Moment, was?
Was?
Was hat genau an Action Adventure mit Blockchain zu tun?
Ich meine, Blockchain macht sich als Buzzword gut.
Was genau hat das mit Blockchain zu tun?
Was?
Was geht da ab?
Was sehe ich da?
Was zum Teufel, da kommt die Mutter aufs Dach geflogen oder was?
Und warum fährt die da irgendwie mit dem Rentnermobil rum?
Was ist das?
Also Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, was wir da gerade gesehen haben.
Aber Blockchain.
Oh, es geht weiter.
Blockchain.
Aber die Musik hat was, wenn die selbst gemacht ist.
Das weiß man bei so Games ja immer nicht, ob die Musik selbst gemacht ist.
Okay, Leute, ich weiß absolut nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Blockchain.
Schach.
Ist eh schon gefauntet.
Ketto-Consparency, was ist das hier?
Banner ist raus, aus Frankreich.
Das Game sieht schon, ne, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Das sieht schon ziemlich blöd aus.
Ich weiß nicht.
Es gibt so Games, die sprechen einen überhaupt nicht an.
Das zeigt schon vom Sehen.
Eine Blockchain ist eine Liste, wo du neue Sachen einfügen kannst.
Allerdings sind die einzelnen Teile quasi über Verschlüsselungstechniken und kryptografische Gegebenheiten miteinander verknüpft.
Also es ist nicht so einfach 1, 2, 3, 4, sondern um von 1 zu 2 zu kommen, ist da halt eine gewisse Logik dazwischen.
So ungefähr.
Ja, dann hast du natürlich noch den Block meistens gehasht, dass du das überprüfen kannst.
Aber was auch immer, das hat mit Games überhaupt nichts zu tun und ist eher so ein Hype-Wort aktuell.
Golrak.
Nein.
Monochrome Games muss ich mir jetzt gerade nicht geben.
Würdest du mir zustimmen, wenn ich sag, dass die Blockchain bisher kein einziges Projekt?
Keine Ahnung.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Was ist das?
Ein Game ohne Screenshot, ohne Video, ohne This is my workspace.
Okay, er hat einen Schreibtisch, der Entwickler. Geil, Poggers Alter.
Der Entwickler hat einen Schreibtisch, ich glaub's nicht.
Hast du schon mal was bei Kickstarter unterstützt?
Ja, schon mehrere Sachen und bei einer wurde schön gescampt.
Bei einer hier, hier wurde ich gescampt auf Kickstarter bei Self-Cleaning-Jeans.
Das hab ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal erzählt, dass ich da gescampt wurde, aber heute passt's thematisch gut dazu.
Hier wurde ich gescampt, ich hab irgendwie das...
Was für ein Paket hab ich gebacked? T-Shirt.
Two Pairs.
Ja, ich glaub irgendwie sowas hab ich gebacked, also ich hab da schon ein bisschen Geld ins Sand gesetzt.
Ich hab ein T-Shirt und eine Jeans im Package gehabt.
Und die haben halt richtig reingescampt.
Guck mal, sieht man irgendwie wie viel die gefunden haben? Guck mal, die haben 310.000 Dollar eingenommen.
Und es hat keiner die Jeans bekommen, richtig.
Ja, letzten Updates sind von April.
Und da sagen sie dann so Dinger wie, ja man kann's jetzt lesen, so nach dem Motto, ja die Rewards werden jetzt verschickt.
Was interessiert mich die Rewards? Also ich will die eigentlichen Produkte haben.
Ja und wenn du hier Kommentare guckst, Scam, Scamas, Scamas ohne Ende.
Also, aber es sah auch einfach überzeugend irgendwie aus.
Ich mein sowas kann schon funktionieren.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Materialien, das kann schon...
Also ich lass mich ja in der Regel nicht so leicht scammen was sowas angeht, aber hier haben sie mich richtig gescampt.
Siehst du und außerdem kriegt man dann die Hot'n'Grills an Start, wenn man diese Hose an hat.
Das hab ich gebacked, da hat's Switch gescampt.
Aber das ist das einzige Mal, wo ich gescampt wurde.
Ich find's geil, dass das einzige Update in dem ganzen Kickstarter Projekt hier ist, dass der Entwickler einen Arbeitsplatz hat.
Ja ach.
Ach ja.
Und wenn man sich in die Hose pisst, ja gut, nachdem es nicht über die Hose laufen kann, dann läuft's raus aus den Beinen, wo sonst?
Top Down Shooter Game About Family and Gangsters.
Null von 6000 Euro.
Jetzt kommen die Highlights aber langsam.
Äh...
Was ist das?
Ein Block.
Das ist jetzt nicht sein Ernst, oder?
Was ist das für ein Video? Was soll uns das zu dem...
What the fuck?
Was gucken wir uns da gerade an?
Was ist das?
Also Leute, mal eure Einschätzung.
Ist das...
Ist das eine Verarschung?
Ist das ein Chebat?
Oder weiter ist es wirklich so?
Was macht der denn da?
Das ist ein Chebat.
Das muss ein Chebat sein, das kann nicht eins gemeint sein.
Noch ein Block.
Und...
Klotextur, keine Ahnung.
Ist das Unity?
Nee, das ist Blender.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Das sieht aus wie irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung, wie ein Taco oder so.
Und wenn war das nicht ein Mexican Developer?
Leute, das ist ein Chebat.
Das ist nicht ernst gemeint.
Das kann nicht sein.
Das muss fake sein.
Das muss... Das glaube ich nicht, dass das ernst gemeint ist.
Was?
Das macht mich fertig, ey.
Was ist das? Alter!
Was zum Teufel? 300.000 Euro?
Weg, weg, weg.
Also Leute, falls ihr eine Casino unterstützen wollt, haut rein.
Der Typ braucht bloß noch 192 Euro.
Wisst ihr was? Eigentlich, ja.
Eigentlich... Oh fuck.
Der Typ... Vergesst.
Der Typ braucht nur 6.581 Euro.
Ich wollte nämlich sagen, wenn er bloß 167 gebraucht hätte,
könnte man das fast becken.
Dann muss er das Game nämlich fertig machen.
Da hat er bestimmt keinen Bock drauf.
Okay, weiter.
Real-Time Strategy Game.
Oh, da gibt es viel zu wenige von.
Where you can go through stages of history.
Also quasi Age of Empires.
Für 100... Ein neues Age of Empires für 192 Euro.
Easy, auf gehts.
Schauen wir uns das mal an.
Next Level, Age of Empires.
Ist das Text-to-Speech?
Das ist Text-to-Speech, oder?
Das kann ich auch, Leute.
Das kann mein Meme-Tool auch.
Guck, Text-to-Speech.
Text-to-Speech.
Man kann sogar Weep-Text-to-Speech.
Ja.
Kann mehr.
Only the human being remains through time.
That is our condition.
Survive, survive, survive.
Winner's Movie Maker.
Discover, discover, discover.
Die Highlights sind dabei.
Our ability to get ahead.
Kommt da noch was dazu?
Kommt da noch was zum Game?
We're here, please.
Nein.
Warum steckt man dann sowas auf Kickstarter?
Macht doch einfach mal so ein bisschen Prototyp-mäßig was fertig.
Und dann kann man es doch auch zeigen, aber...
Sowas hier.
First Gameplay Update.
Oh, das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Leute, das Gameplay Update, das muss jetzt sein.
Sie sieht wirklich aus wie Age of Empires.
Also von den Kühen.
Ich mein...
Die maximal möglichen FPS werden natürlich wieder ausgereizt gerade.
Ein Krokodile.
Ist das russisch?
Moment.
Gibt es da noch mehr außer ein paar Tiere, die im Kreis laufen?
Wohlgemerkt, das soll ein Age of Empires werden.
So eine Art Age of Empires.
Aktuell sieht man Tiere im Kreis hobsen.
Was zum Teufel?
Was ist das?
Sabler toothed.
Tiggled.
Ey.
Keine Ahnung.
Das verwirrt mich.
Übrigens, warum machen die nicht einfach Malen?
Vielleicht ist das Game ja gar nicht schlecht.
Vielleicht...
Warum macht man nicht erstmal einen Prototyp, wo man ein bisschen was zeigen kann?
Ein bisschen, ja?
Wenn man das ernst meint, dann kann man das doch auch zeigen.
Ich kann da von mir zum Beispiel, die wollen eine VR-Halle aufmachen, also mit...
Wie heißt das?
Mit so...
Wie nennt sich das dann?
Also sprich, wo du in so einem Gestell drin stehst und eine Brille aufhast und dann im
Endeffekt so ein bisschen Call of Duty Singleplayer spielst.
Es ist nicht wirklich Call of Duty Singleplayer, es ist halt auf Action gemacht.
Was machen die als erstes gerade?
Die bauen nen Prototyp.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja?
Und das hat tatsächlich Potenzial.
Ich mein, da hast du nen Gestell, hast deine Brille auf, kannst bis zu drei Spielern irgendwie
quasi gegen Computer spielen.
Das kann tatsächlich was werden, aber um zu gucken, ob das was wird, was machen sie, sie
bauen nen Prototyp.
Und das macht halt sonst irgendwie keiner.
Und die gehen da richtig ran.
Ich mein, so ein Gestell, wo man sich, so ein VR-Gestell, wisst ihr das, wo man laufen kann,
links und rechts und sowas, das kostet 6k ein Stück.
Ich hab auch gedacht, the fuck.
Aber die meinen es halt ernst, ja?
Sollte das was werden, wär ich da wahrscheinlich auch mal ein Video von machen, weil ich mein,
bisschen Promotion schadet den Jungs bestimmt nicht.
So.
Weiter.
Epidemic, hatten wir sowas nicht vorher schon mal?
Minecraft Zombies oder sowas?
Ok, die haben auch wieder kein Video.
Machen wir nicht.
Das Laser Grill!
Ja endlich, endlich war ein Game für mich.
Aber leider auch kein Gameplay.
Guter Name, leider kein Gameplay.
Dump little creatures, ist das sowas wie Lemmings oder sowas?
Help a group of innocent creatures avoided, das ist sowas wie Lemmings.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Oder Pikmin.
Oh, die FPS-Anzahl wird voll ausgereizt.
Ok, eher wie Lemmings.
Pikmin-Lemmings.
Roller-FPS für jedes Auge, zwei Stück.
Es ist im Endeffekt sowas wie Lemmings.
Ok, wenn er Bock drauf hat, fehlen bloß noch 9000 Euro.
Nur noch 9000 Euro, 22 Tage to go.
Absolut flüssiges Gameplay, jawohl.
Sache, zwei FPS für jedes Auge, zwei Stück.
Insgesamt vier.
Strong Moon, 2D-Plattformer.
Game inspired by Super Mario World und Donkey Kong Country.
Also quasi zwei der besten jemals gemachten 2D-Plattformer.
Soon you can help Strong Moon.
Wer zum Teufel ist Strong Moon?
Erda, oder was?
Was zum Teufel?
What the fuck?
Ok, wir kommen nochmal darauf zurück, was die ursprünglich geschrieben haben.
Inspired by Super Mario World und Donkey Kong Country.
Es hat mal absolut gar nichts mit Mario World zu tun.
Es hat auch immer irgendwie gar nichts mit Donkey Kong Country zu tun.
Also mit Mario World schon mal absolut gar nichts.
Null.
Da ist Batman.
Und Captain America.
Nee, der ist nicht da.
Die Guardians of the Galaxy sind da.
Und Spider-Man ist da. Was hat er denn damit zu tun?
Eure Augen, das ist natürlich schon...
Es ist ja schon nah dran, ja.
Hat schon fast was von... Egal.
Wer 2,5K loswerden will.
Strong Moon, 2D-Plattformer.
Läuft noch 17 Tage.
Becken.
Hazelnut Bastille.
16-Bit Indie-Adventure.
Ok, das ist schon was, was mir optisch erstmal ganz gut gefällt.
Wenn es was taugt.
Schauen wir mal.
Hat auch schon gut gebacked.
Man kann immer ganz gut unterscheiden zwischen
Leute können 2D-Grafik und Leute können nicht 2D-Grafik.
Und das hier sieht auf dem Screenshot schon mal ganz danach aus, als können sie 2D-Grafik.
Das Voice-Over bräuchte ich jetzt nicht.
Aber das macht einen guten Eindruck.
Man kann sogar rennen.
Das Waschgrill ist auch am Start.
Mit Inventar.
Die Grafik gefällt mir.
Der Wind muss es in jedem Game geben.
Ey, der Gegner eben, ne?
Der könnte eins zu eins aus dem Spiel auf Mana kommen.
Auch mit den Fackeln hier, das sieht schon recht ähnlich.
Ich hoffe, das ist Ingame-Musik und nicht nur Trailer-Musik.
Das weißte, hier sieht man wenigstens auch Gameplay.
Hier sieht man, dass die Leute schon mal was gemacht haben.
Man sieht hier, dass es stimmig zusammenpasst.
Alles, was ich bei den meisten Games vermisse, was man hier auf Kickstarter dazu gesehen hat.
Schreckt.
Und auch richtig cooler 2D-Style gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist nice.
So was kann man noch mal backen.
Und das sehen anscheinend glücklicherweise auch noch andere Leute so.
Also sprich, es werden nicht nur Weep-Grafik-Novels gefoundet, sondern auch noch ordentliche Games.
Und die brauchen noch ein bisschen Kohle für die Stretchgoals.
More Content, Localization.
Gameplay brauche ich nicht unbedingt, Nintendo Switch brauche ich auch nicht unbedingt, aber vielleicht habe ich da was zu spielen.
24 Tage to go, die werden auf jeden Fall noch ordentlich Kohle machen, hoffe ich mal.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall backen, das macht einen guten Eindruck.
Wieder da.
Weiter.
Wie viele Games in der Richtung haben wir eigentlich heute noch?
Und mal wieder keine Vorschau.
Oh, das ist wieder Pedobear-Alarm.
Monster Sanctuary, Monster Taming, Metroidvania.
Wieder ein Game, was auf den ersten Blick schon mal so aussieht, als wissen die Leute, wie man 2D-Grafik macht.
Hier sind rundenbasierte Fight-Stells-Kram.
Ganz netter Soundtrack.
Terraria Pokémon, ihr habt ein bisschen was von.
Das Movement sieht auch schon mal viel flüssiger aus, als bei den ganzen anderen Cup-Games, die wir heute gesehen haben.
Das kommt aus Frankfurt, oder?
Ach, deswegen kam mir der Typ so bekannt vor.
Der hier, den kenne ich vom Hauptbahnhof.
Bam.
Yoshi, nein, eine Raupe.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe null gecheckt, was eigentlich genau passiert, aber mir gefällt die Optik und das Sound.
Und das sehen anscheinend auch noch mehr so.
Ich meine, 65k von 20.000 Gold. Aus Frankfurt kommt das Ganze. Wie heißt denn der Hersteller?
Moiraigames.
Was haben die da sonst noch so?
Sind die nicht weit weg?
Wo sind die denn?
Offenbach.
Half die Abi.
Ja, das hat mir gefallen, das Game.
Oh nee, das nächste ist ja schon wieder.
Nee, keine Graphic Novel, okay.
Das hat mir gefallen und das kann man auf jeden Fall unterstützen.
Es sieht nicht schlecht aus, Sound war auch sehr nice.
Und das sehen anscheinend auch mehr so.
65k von 20.000 schon gebacked, 18 Tage to go, da kommt auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen was rum.
Und ansonsten gibt es einfach nur noch weitere Stretchgoals.
Wir hatten jetzt zwei gute Games hintereinander, was denn da los?
Jetzt muss wieder eigentlich irgendein Mist kommen.
Moin Tomica.
Jetzt muss echt zwei gute Games hintereinander, das kann eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Da stimmt was nicht.
Fake News.
Okay, weiter.
Midnight Wave, Cyberpunk, Samurai, Tactical Platform Fighter.
Boah, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Da hatten wir es doch vorher schon, dass Games heute nicht mehr zu einem Genre gehören, sondern die sonst wie was alles immer mischen.
Cyberpunk, Samurai, Tactical Platform Fighter.
Okay, das sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Das Vorschaubild ist schon mal eindeutig dieser Kategorie hier zuzuordnen.
So wie vieles heutzutage schon, äh wie heute Abend schon.
5K von 41.000.
Moment, was ist denn?
Was denn, ist das eine Top-Down-2D-Strategie oder nicht?
Oder so ein bisschen Fire Emblem ist?
Was?
Okay.
Ist es jetzt 2D von oben Strategie gewesen oder 2D von der Seite Prawl-mäßig?
Geralt.
Also, beim besten Willen.
Ich wäre ja auf so ziemlich alles gekommen, bloß dich auf Geralt gerade.
Jetzt, jetzt wo ihr es sagt, jetzt fällt mir das auch auf.
Die Ähnlichkeit ist bestechend, ja.
Zumindest mal ein ordentlicher Kickstarter-Seite.
Allein schon deswegen ist es das wert, sich mal anzugucken.
Okay.
Okay, einen Durchgang können wir noch machen.
Dann ist ja schon fast 22 Uhr.
Every inch.
Oh, Penobäher-Alarm wieder.
Noch mehr, sag mal, wie viele Visual Novels gibt es eigentlich, bin ich schon heute Abend.
Das ist ja gefühlt, ist ein Drittel der Game, irgendwelche Geschichten.
Okay, Acute in the Open World MMORPG.
Ein MMO, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ein MMO für 10K.
Schauen wir mal.
Das Schwert ist ein bisschen groß, oder?
Was ist denn das?
Wartet mal.
Was, was genau soll das hier sein?
Das hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Das hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, finde ich.
So entfernt zumindest.
Depressed Royal Guardians, würde ich auch depressed sein, wenn ich so ausschauen würde, ey.
Depressed Penguin.
Ein bisschen Animal Crossing mit dabei.
MMOs sind zu groß für kleine Teams.
Ich traue es einfach keinem Team zu, mit nur ein paar Leuten ein großes MMO zu machen.
MMOs sind einfach so ein riesiges Ding an Aufwand.
Loot.
Zumindest haben sie schon mal Gameplay zum zeigen.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, es geht bei Kickstarter immer darum, dass man irgendwie an die Projekte glaubt.
Ein MMO über Kickstarter von einem kleinen Team.
Ich zähle aber bloß 16 Tage noch.
Da glaube ich leider nicht dran, dass das was wird.
Vielleicht seht ihr das anders.
Habt ihr noch Zeit 16 Tage zu becken, 9000 Euro.
Na ja, vollenbreit 10.000 Euro, dass das Ganze was wird.
Wir haben sogar ein Instagram-Account.
Die wollen es wissen, oder?
Ah, da ist nichts drauf.
Will you be my friend, a short story adventure explorer.
Schon, schon, schon ge-founded.
Investiert magst du auch selber.
Ja, ein paar Sachen haben wir schon gespeichert, die ich ziemlich gut fand.
Nope.
Was ist das?
Hä?
Team Disorder the Game.
This is floating with Team Disorder the 3D Game.
Was?
Okay, die Domänen gibt's nicht mal.
Nice.
Perfekt.
Okay.
Wer kriegen wir über das Game nicht raus, außer das hier?
Keine Ahnung, so Moki Island Verschnitt oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Das versprüht richtig Qualität, ja.
Next.
Fast Action Puzzle Game.
Okay, die haben, also sorry, vergesst.
Ich wollte sagen, die haben nichts außer den Video, aber haben sie doch.
Na, das gucken wir uns ja nicht an.
Das sieht nicht nur nach meinem aus.
Every inch Football Game.
Gibt's nichts dazu.
Zelle.
Fantasy Hall Adventure Game.
Schwammelschleim.
Oh nee.
Ich weiß ja irgendwie nicht so genau, ob das was ist.
Zelle.
Death.
Keine Ahnung, irgendwie spricht's mich mal überhaupt nicht an.
Ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Zelle.
So da bin ich wieder, ich hoffe ich habe keine epileptischen Anfälle bekommen, alle noch
am leben ja falscher knopf au xqc subs am start
any moxers in chat ok weiter geht's stript swipper
wippers weibers wenn booty calls oh ich ahne ich ahne schlimmes
sagt man diesen hintergrund den haben wir doch schon mal gesehen heute bei
irgendeinem anderen game oder du würdest ja auch sagen ja ich weiß ich weiß ich
weiß ich muss mich da echt endlich mal drum kümmern
hey everyone my name is joshua cascana and i'm the creator of striped swipers so
what is striped swipers when booty calls well it's a comedy point-and-click
adventure game that i've been working on kind of the service of love letter to
games like sam and mac
the island gave the tentacle etc the striped wipers himself have existed for a
while the original idea of these burglars came when i had a couple of years i always
loved how they would steal from each other and try to hide their loot i've
turned to kickstarter because while i'm writing coding and doing a lot of the
animation and character art i'm only one person i'm a bit musically challenged
and can't exactly voice acting your help would actually allow me to pay for things
like voice acting music and all the other costs and stuff that come with
making a game not to mention it would allow me to spend more time working on
the project as a show of good faith a demo will be relieved and it will actually be a little rough around the edges but i hope
seeing the world and characters will make you hungry for more i'll be aiming for a
2019 i was geben im partner help me on my journey and to where we can find
gefällt mireled mounting ting cache aber Skillfeld 7000 euro braucht 14 tage
zeit
Next Collateral Damage
Battle Over Thysan Knight
Das sieht gar nicht mal
so schlecht aus
Gucken wir mal
Ein 3D Hero Arena Brawler
Was ist das?
So was wie Overwatch
Bloß als Kampfgame
Oh jawoll, jetzt gehts ab
Oh es sieht hochgradig verwirrend aus
Neun Tyler 55
Es sieht hochgradig verwirrend aus
Was seh ich da genau?
Ich seh nen 4er Splitscreen
PvP Modus oder so
Also Leute ich checke absolut nichts
Vor allem das ist ein Hero im Splitscreen mit 4 Leute
WTF
Da flippst du ja voll aus im Kopf
Oh Musik intensifies
Ah 04
Weit kein Unity
Okay
Ja
Weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
Passiert viel
Nichts für Leute mit epileptischen Problemen
Ja also
14.000 Euro brauchen sie noch
44 Tage Zeit
Aufgegstarte
Oh
Ist schon ge-Founded
Oh Scheiße kann ich das jetzt anmachen?
Ohne dass ich gebannt werde
A holy night
So sieht ein holy night also aus
Mit wenig drunter
Diese Games warum gibt es davon so viele
Warum gibt es davon so viele Games
Oh jetzt gehts ab
Aiaiai
Besser gesagt Aiaiai
Oh da gehts
Da gehts richtig ab
Ja diese Games
Und wisst ihr was ich toll finde
Schon komplett ge-Founded
Okay
Ganz ehrlich Leute ich hab Schiss das Video anzumachen
Soll ich
Oder soll ich nicht
Ich hab ein bisschen je nachdem was da kommt
Bei Twitch sind sie nicht ganz so zimperlich
Egal ich muss gar nicht fragen
Ihr sagt eh alle ja
Das war schon klar
Okay
Oh habt ihr das gelesen?
Aha
Weep Games
Da ist das Video war ja gar nichts
Gabs ja gar nichts zu sehen drinne
Dazu
Da fällt mir eins bloß noch ein
Ähm
Ja gut also
Ist schon ge-Founded müsst ihr nicht mehr becken
Aber diese
Die gehen ab
Die gehen echt ab die sind alle ge-Founded
Wie teuer solls sein da ist es schon vorbei
150 Leute gebacked
19 Tage verbleiben
Das heißt da kommen noch ein paar stretchgoals oder so dazu
Okay weiter gehts
SCP
Ich verstehe unter SCP was anderes
Aber das werden die meisten Leute jetzt nicht hervollziehen können
SCP ist quasi SSH zum Datei übertragen
Nur mal so angemerkt
A Blackout
Ist VR Desktop Horror Game
Ein Horror Game
Da hatten wir heute schon erstaunlich
Wenige von
Eine Forschungsfab
Oh
Ob es da auch Spodas gibt
Gucken wir mal
Achja wieviel wollen sie eigentlich
43 Euro warum
Warum stellt man so Games rein ich versteh das nicht
Warum warum
Was ich mein 43 Euro macht
Kein Unterschied
Ob du jetzt 43 Euro hast oder nicht
Davon kannst du jetzt auch nicht
Mehr entwickeln als vorher
Was soll das bringen
Hä
Keine Ahnung
Das ist so Dead Space
Für Arme
Die Tür geht auf
Okay
Wirklich was gesehen hat man davon jetzt noch nicht
Man kann Discord Join
Also
Wenn ihr das gerne noch mehr unterstützen wollt
Dann ich speichere mir das mal
Wir sehen den Monat was da rausgekommen ist
Für 43 Euro
Dann könnt ihr noch mehr backen
Dass er sich vielleicht auch noch
Ein paar Assets kaufen kann
Oder so
Okay weiter gehts
Okultus
Retro Platforming Action
Classic Horror
Okay
Soll das ein bisschen Castlevania mäßig werden
Also 558 von 5700
Okultus
Ja das ist wirklich ein bisschen Castlevania mäßig
Bloß ohne Peitsche
Hat mir gerade einer donatet
Das hab ich gar nicht richtig gehört
Muss ich mal gucken
Hat wirklich gerade einer donatet
Der Tyler hat
Donatet
Smiley
Ich meine das Gameplay sieht
Jetzt nicht gerade spannend aus
Die Musik finde ich ganz nice
Das Gameplay sieht
Wirklich langweilig aus
Immer den gleichen Nahkampf
Angriff
Doch nicht immer der gleiche Nahkampf
Ja das ist schon richtig
Hat halt einer geschrieben
Aber ist nicht besser ein niedriges Ziel zu haben
Wenn man sein Ziel nicht erreicht
Kriegt man doch gar nichts
Das ist richtig aber was machst du mit 43 Euro
Was machst du mit 43 Euro
Kannst dir zwei Assets aus dem Asset Store kaufen
Ob es das Game besser macht
Dann lieber sowas hier wo du auch ein bisschen was mit anfangen kannst
43 Euro
Da kannst du dir noch nicht mal eine Monatskarte von kaufen
Okay also wem das gefallen hat
Brauchen noch 5000 Euro 13 Tage verbleibend
Hyper Pixel 11000
211 von 878
Das ist bestimmt wieder so ein Epilepsy Game
Was sehe ich da gerade
Was wie 12 Fortress oder so
Was passiert da
Ach da bewegt sich was
WTF ich wollte gerade sagen ich habe es überhaupt nicht gesehen
Das sieht schon scheiße aus
Sorry aber es sieht schon
Und ich meine es kostet nichts
Aber es sieht schon echt eklig aus
Da tun mir die Augen beim zugucken weh
Sieht aus wie ein Beckens Spiel aus dem Happy Meal
Das stimmt aber auch von den Farben her
Hahaha
Oh jetzt wird es noch mehr intens
Also das zerstört wirklich mein Auge
Das kann er ja nicht spielen
Das ist ja noch kleiner
Der Pixel ist noch zu groß
Okay also wer gerne mal seine Augen zerstören möchte
Hyper Pixel 11000
Jetzt auf Kickstarter fehlt auch nicht mehr viel
Das heißt wenn ihr den Entwicklern unterstützen wollt
Dann könnt ihr ihm gleich volle Ladung plätschen und Gutes
Oh
Hatten wir ja heute Abend schon so wenige
Oh die wollen gleich mal 11000
Die anderen Niveau Visual Novels haben sich ja wenigstens mit 1000 oder so zufrieden gegeben
Moment das ist nicht nur eine Visual Novel
Das ist sogar noch eine Dating Sim ist auch noch dabei
Und Japanese Voice Acting
Oh Japanese Voice
Das ist ja für die
Da flippen die Vibes aber aus
Wobei ich sagen muss der Grafiksteen sieht halt nicht so toll aus
Das sahen die anderen Manga Grills aber schon deutlich besser aus
Ich will nur mal gucken ob sie wirklich Voice Acting drin haben
Ah man ist neu in der Schule
Wer hätte das gedacht von der Story her
Der Kopf passt überhaupt nicht zum Rest oder
Das ist nicht schön gemalt
Also die andere
WTF
Oh
Ich weiß nicht
Da haben mir die anderen Visual Novels aber besser gefallen
Außerdem wollen die viel zu viel Geld haben
Aber wenn es euch gefällt
Ich meine Grafikstile sind Geschmackssache
Ja wahrscheinlich
Aber jedem was jedem das seine
Ihr wollt das jetzt ja nicht schlecht machen
Also wenn euch der Grafikstil gefällt
Dann habt ihr 14 Tage Zeit
Für 11.000 Euro
Live 2D ist erstaunlich teuer
Ja ich sehs
Aber mir gefällt das Stil nicht
Morpheus
A local multiplayer 2D racing game
Das ist ja fast so klein wie der Pixel von dem Game vorhin
Kein Sound schonmal
Schau mal kein Sound
Und UI des Todes ey
Also wenn einer sagt
Er will ein Spiel machen
Dann sollte er auch ein besseres UI hinkriegen
Wie ich
Ich mein mein UI ist schon nicht schön
Aber es ist Funktional
Und es sieht besser aus
Als das
Ich find mein UI gar nicht so hässlich
Es ist halt Funktional
Klickste drauf
Wirds angezeigt
Fertig
Mehr muss es ja nicht können
Themes kannst du umschalten
Light Theme kannst du einschalten
Du kannst nen Tab aufmachen
Für OBS Integration
Tja
Und neue Memes uploaden
Das wars im Prinzip
Mehr muss es aber auch nicht können
Achso du kannst noch
Du kannst noch suchen nach Bildchen
Aber das wars, mehr musst du auch nicht können
Gibts demnächst raus
Und los auf GitHub
Klick auf
Auf ihn hier solls klicken
Das wie gesagt ist Interface ist gedacht
Um so nen zweiten Rechner zu verwenden
Was ich auch die ganze Zeit übrigens schon mache
Was meint ihr wo die Bilder herkommen
Den Gaben hab ich auch
Ja klar
Ok gucken wirs uns an
Ist es so Micromachines
In
Schlecht
Ich finds geil wie der Sound knackt
Wenn das Video losgeht
So als wollte er
Der Sound runter machen
Aber es hat nicht funktioniert
Schon wieder ein Kackspiel aus Frankreich
Frankreich
Wir wollen sie mal nicht zu sehr flamen
Also
Wer euch das angesprochen hat
Dann
Habt ihr noch 13 Tage Zeit für 1000 Euro
Our Generation
Gameset 1964 around
Mods enter
Sie wollen
284.000
Haben
Von Overwatch
Games
Ok
Was soll denn das sein
Der Zahnausschlag Simulator
Gameset
warum also was geht es überhaupt
es scheint leider nicht so viele leute zu interessieren wie es aussieht
ok wenn ihr sagt ihr könnt mal kurz so eine viertel viertel millionen mal raushauen nebenbei ich war mal ganz sicher sonst nichts
könnt ihr our generation 1964 founden die haben sie auf jeden fall nötig 13 tage verbleiben viele updates haben sie geschrieben
das läuft schon eine weile und interessiert keinen so wirklich
so ganz kapiert habe ich es nicht
ok leute das ist schon 22.15 wollen wir noch eine runde machen
komm eine runde machen wir noch irgendwie macht das spaß es sind ja auch die eine nicht schon wieder oder
alter visual novels ohne ende ohne ende
das sieht jetzt tatsächlich ganz gut aus
die leute scheinen nicht so überzeugt zu sein
das ist wirklich ein fire game
man sitzt im bett und leuchte die gegner an
ich meine
ich meine einfach nur da sitzen auf irgendwas leuchten ist jetzt nur oder so die spanung pur
die sollten sich mal die bettel viel drei taschenlampen drauf machen da kam die monster nichts mehr zu lachen
man sitzt auf dem sofa oder im betten leuchten mit taschenlampe geile sache
alpha theory in die roguelike dungeon crawler
oder findet ihr nicht auch es ist sehr isaac style
ja eindeutig
ja das ist quasi ein bisschen wie isaac
ich meine optisch ist ganz hübsch finde ich ein bisschen langsam ist es also die jungs brauchen noch in 28 tagen brauchen sie noch 25 k
also wenn ihr fan von solchen games seid dann haut rein da ist es
wenn euch sowas interessiert
mein fall ist es nicht maga the game play es doch
ich ahne schlimmes leute ich ahne schlimmes bei solchen games
das soll lustig sein
also solche games sollen lustig sein aber ich finde sie nicht lustig ich finde sie eher ziemlich bescheuert
wahrscheinlich findet man das auch plus lustig wenn man sich damit auseinander gesetzt hat
ok ja wer auf sowas steht easy money 13 tage verbleibend
wie viele haben wir davon heute eigentlich schon gehabt
das hat ja gar nicht mehr auf founded founded leute was sonst founded
diese games sind immer founded hatten wir heute ein jedoch wir hatten das das 29.000 game was nicht founded ist founded alles founded
das muss man es nicht gibt es ja gar kein video kann man es gar nicht angucken
so wusch ho do next f 0
sieht das schlecht aus
looping was gucken wir uns denn da wieder an
ne leute das muss nicht sein
das ist die ultimate multiplayer hover jet fun zone
klingt auch schon so ein euro von 8000 also wer schon immer mal die ultimative multiplayer hover jet fun zone spielen wollte kann ja
das sieht aber nicht nach meinem geschmack aus
was ist für eine animation
das sieht doch wirklich aus als pink lehrer hin oder jetzt weht ein bisschen wind von der seite
der fotosaut dabei auch 25 kills am start
naja
in der echtzeit strategie spiele braucht das land ich weiß nicht ob wir das brauchen
was das fantasy dark gothic ccg card card game oder was was ist ccg
tausend euro ja für was denn
ja für was
ja
50 euro games oder so meinetwegen aber 240.000 dollar euro
wie den rhythmus game habe ich jetzt eigentlich keinen bock drauf
das neue fit
ja ok du schlägst den feuer die dinger weg
ach deswegen hat die was von work out erzählt weil dann da steht sie quasi hier
ich bin leider nicht so überzeugt gerade
leute ihr seid ein was schon gemein ja 240 euro 240.000 euro dass er zum friseur kann
das ist geklaut von was beat saber sagt mir überhaupt nichts
aha kenne ich nicht also cooles rift demo game
basiert auf was
ist denn srd ist es in den tanzens und trance upcoming
ich weiß nicht was es ist aber 5 e 5 e klingt nach tanzens und trance
bin ich mal gespannt zeigt mal her kann es gar nicht genug geben von solchen
games passfinder war nice plus eins war nice
aus sieben minuten müssen sie vorspulen
hallo
game nicht game video please
jetzt ist das hexfeld stellt ja
liegt es an mir dass es ruckelt oder ruckelt es einfach gerade massiv
ich meine ich mag so games ja
ich finde so klassich RPGs kann es gar nicht genug geben
ich weiß leider nicht was srd 3.5 e ist 3.5 e klingt halt sehr nach irgendeiner
älteren tanzens und trance ausgabe vom rule set her was ja schon mal die übel
mehr das sieht eigentlich auch ganz nice aus
und bis in civilization style nicht civilization might magic style
ich meine das könnte was sein und das sehen auch noch andere leute so weil ich
in 77.000 von 100k erreicht
das sieht mir schon ein bisschen zu sehr auf bald aufs geld gemacht aus
beziehungsweise auf infinite wie ist das infinity engine
games ist recht ähnlich aber ganz ehrlich
klassich RPGs kann es im prinzip nie genug geben also wenn ihr auch so was
steht dann haut rein 11 tage zeit speichern wir das auch mal muss ich mir
nachher noch mal in ruhe angucken so die drei machen wir jetzt noch aber dann ist
es wieder graphic novel dating sim und ein letztes dating sim ich weiß nicht ob
ich mir das jetzt angucken soll das zeug ist immer fast gebäckt diese
dinge die gehen weg wie geschnitten poten ohne scheiß
game with remote controlled robots over internet wat
rasch b
staubsauger robotter als panzer getarnt
kontrolle real robots online aber warum warum kann ich die nicht offline
also wenn wo ist der sind da oder kann ich da meinen robot dahinschicken und
der fährt dann darum und und andere
ah ja ok aber man fährt mit echten robottern in einer miniature stadt rum und
ballert sich gegenseitig ab das klingt total abgedreht irgendwie aber warum
nicht ich verstehe zwar nicht so genau den vorteil davon wenn man remote
controlled quasi über kamera dann so ganz verstehe ich es nicht aber warum man
das dann nicht in dem game machen kann aber es ist halt real und es sind robotter
und es ist übers internet das heißt man hat ein bisschen leck dabei ja warum nicht
klingt zumindest irgendwie ganz cool also wenn er bock drauf hat hat noch zeit
25 tage das ganze zu becken in einer chernobyl copy area ist man unterwegs
und fährt mit eigenen robottern rum ich meine von der ide her finde ich das
eigentlich ganz cool ich weiß zwar nicht so genau warum warum ich das cool
finde aber ich finde ganz gut sind sie dann auch drinne und best mein panzer
weg die haben das aber schon ganz gut nachgebaut ich glaube sie sind da
wahrscheinlich einfach nur für die optik drin dass die leute sich die
fotos angucken ok aber das ist doch nice gemacht so noch mal ein neues game für
den es ist auch schon erreicht ist schon gefauntet
ist schon gefauntet muss man nicht mal faulden ok leute wir haben jetzt glaube
ich irgendwie vier stunden oder so aber jedes ging übelst schnell rum die zeit
wir haben fast vier stunden kickstarter und krasser scheiß all vier stunden ich
glaube es nicht an ok leute ich hoffe es gefallen wenn ihr wollt können wir das
öfters machen ich fand das eigentlich ganz witzig
wir waren an der stelle entschluss ich bin müde ich gehe jetzt pennen hoffen wir
auch für euch genauso nice wie für mich
und ihr wisst was das heißt leute wir haben einen schluss machts gut bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
m